[Music]
welcome podcast all right and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 79 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord who in my
opinion is the epitome of a true gamer
and whom I had the absolute pleasure of
meeting in the flesh at e3 2018 this
Lord is not only one of the most
technically proficient content creators
in the game but his wealth of gaming
dollars is truly a sight to behold
whether it be his technical analysis of
current gen platforms or his retro
series all done with nostalgic fields
and outstanding video production
introducing the premier tech tester and
video producer for digital foundry the
writer for Eurogamer Lord of gaming
benchmarks and human fraps in the flesh
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord's mummy Lord John Lennon how you
doing sir - good I'm not sure I can live
up to that in the realm absolute
pleasure to have you all aboard it do so
it's only right we show you two probably
respect here at the Roundy oh man I
appreciate it sir nice you guys it's
it's great to be here so thanks for
having me absolute pleasure to have you
man we are going to have some fun all
right and of course you know we have the
Four Horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the Co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict how're you doing sir doing
pretty good I was going to actually play
other games this week he talked found
out the raid and destiny was like 30
light lowest higher than it was both so
now guess what I've been doing
for the past three days what it was
supposed to be I didn't think the final
encounter would be in the eighties yeah
it was it was a rough go for the Lord's
just say that starting that race the
effects friendships will be we survived
we kept any because you've been played
it at reference to uh what sighs nothing
no ok so just be hardcore you getting
that grinder was the light level looking
like I just hit the 40's nice getting
ready first encounter be let's do it and
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Thomas mister offline
luminary and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man Lord sovereign how are you
doing sir I'm doing fantastic today you
know a little bit of getting it over
some inebriation from you know voice
sounding a little sexy little is a good
spot you really picked a good spot
we like that so I finally finished by
the man oh my god messed up on the
Platinum I'm gonna have to well the
thing is I used some taskmaster tokens
on things instead of my unlocking my
suits so the hide taskmaster like the
third-level taskmaster stuff is kind of
like you need some really high scores so
I gotta get back in there and grind that
stuff out to get the platinum but
finally finish a season trophy chases or
a completely different kind man
[Laughter]
so pretty I'm taking I'm like looking at
every little corner every little thing
like we do for kids we don't perform its
movements often oh I'm running it I'm
running it at 4k 30 frames per second
was the 60 frames guy no the thing is I
was I'm disappointed that there's no
enriched mode I really like that and
with that middle ground in rich mode
yeah the higher frame rate right it
gives you the higher frame rate and it
gives you more of like the effects so I
decided to go with the 30 frames per
second forward because I just really
wanted to see they came in rich mode was
like the that was a great feature yeah
I'm a little disappointed in the four as
a demo for not having something kind of
middle to like I the first time I like I
didn't rich mode what was what would the
benchmark what was the the stats from
that as far as what oh yeah so on xbox 1
X it was just like Brandon checkerboard
of working ok Oh
checkerboard 4k is what the ps4 pro
version was doing but not in enriched
mode
neck's it was either you get native 4k
or you get checkerboard 4k and if you
went with enriched you just got a lot of
the extra details at the PC we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka sports who
is a man of his convictions that means
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert boom
Tim Dogg and everybody else I wish you
two made it yesterday brother stand
things be out of people patrol the
Lord's got together yesterday for a lot
of drink and watching the fight the
results will be up later on today
because we know we're early so this will
be the time I'm doing combat talk it's
not
I have been after this fraud for about
let me why I've been fraud
I've been fraud in I'm a fraud my
spider-man is still in the wrapper
purchased it out of spite
a purchase is out of spite to spite Lord
addict to make sure they're bought the
whole truck I wish I wish I bet between
Lord Anakin Lord King as far as God of
War vs. spider-man first month's sales
so that's the inside I'm in the
spider-man camp but I want to give us a
shout out to all the frauds that thought
they was gonna actually jump in the raid
and be a day one winning my team stood
back the witness I did look a step back
they said no we don't get our light
level up shout out to the floors that
apparently there's people that's doing
the first part couple parts of that
sectors in the mid 30s getting the
mechanics mechanics thing you can
actually be damaged but it ramps up
severely right after that which I knew
and I don't deal but I actually thought
there's go try and I say I'm walking you
back this week to grind again shout out
I'm not gonna you know who you are
the person the team who beat them right
there and almost in the 60s like 59 I
said one of them was 566 really oh wow
yes seventeen hours that stream with
wait long salute clan I believe older
guys to that glad dude
why I never seen someone like his chato
was literally blowing up in the middle
of his stream and he just didn't know
what to say about that really emotional
you could tell at the toll of it I
believe it was down him and dad Oh dad I
was still going he went 24 hours he
still completed even though our clan
redeemer you all you started okay got
you know who a second I have no clue it
was probably that team that was with the
that was on the same level as that other
team because there was two people at the
very end and the funny part is like no
one expected that rate to go past the
final ball it was tremendous racial ooh
Bungie fantastic if you ever to see a
see and radar community it's one of the
best cooperative experiences in gaming
shout to those guys that grinded it on
day one at those light levels I don't
know what I did
the funny thing is he was like after his
chat was blown up with subscriptions as
love he was like I only beat array think
of the rate in terms like comparing it
to other ones um it's early but it I'll
put it like this mean a toccata
discussion offline it's already in
contention for I mean because right now
I'm saying I think this way destiny fans
right now hold vault of glass and taking
a lot of processes favorites as the top
rates ever in destiny and already do you
think it surpassed taking King just
based on the bosses to scope the length
the difficulty narrative they have a
narrative that's cohesive through the
raid which has never been done before
it's really good so it just comes I
think we just got to do a couple more
clears you know I'm saying it get the
crested community up he's only about 1%
of the computer really this completed it
you know until more people get then I
think you know um you know we'll start
there I think right now there's only
eight people who's beaten 18 yeah so I
mean but from what we've seen man it
looks fantastic it really it may have
outdone themselves with this one and of
course what I think will be ready
buffering yeah we and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
Lord Cognito spreading that realness in
the realm of the ILP now telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so for me which is really simple
like I said that's neat too as well I
to k-19 I want the switch it is
fantastic feature-rich shout out to my
man hardhead he was very worried about
our 2k 18 they were a couple of features
that were missing maybe our face can
with the app and also three-on-three
molding full online features I mean 2k
really pulled out well it has been
determined that Nintendo was not doing
cloud saves for 2k 19 however everything
about 2k back to the server based on
their own server so you have to even be
online to do a lot of simple things so
luckily in this case if something
happened to my data its responsibility I
bet you ever got their subscription
again you will never gonna miss out that
payment again I picked up shout out to
the messenger those guys over there
devolver digital much oh yeah yeah man
I'm a huge ninja game fan so it's like
just to play it really has that
8/5 of ninja gaiden nes and you know you
got your platforming and your skills and
the game was low-key funny like even if
you go to like um item shops it's like a
mysterious item shop and like like the
game allows you to question the shop
manager like okay so why am I here what
am I doing this he's like dude the game
just started too early to be asking
these questions just keep it's a let it
breaks the third wallet it's funny
hilarious is indeed 8-bit retro if you
love Ninja Gaiden all those type of
side-scrolling games where skills get
acquired you are gonna love this game
shout out to those guys over there
fantastic game
so let's patrol we play will we as
impact right
max Eastman shout-out to uh forget his
name um Fieri the area from all who sat
down one of your tabs over there and
created fantastic guy just to see the
game finally come out man yeah they
treated as well - absolutely yes we got
into what the Lord's are playing what a
start off with a lordly Lebanon video
game system history his journey as a
writer for Eurogamer and video producer
for digital foundry and of course what
let him become the creator and Lord of
all things retro so Lord John let's
start from the very beginning what are
the some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you in a game oh
man that goes back a long way but I
think the first actual console I had was
the Atari 2600 26 always does good and
from there I got the Gameboy okay yeah I
actually had to save up my own money to
get that one I started off with Megaman
game boy good a good card yeah I liked
the heck so yeah it started like way
back then and you know got some of the
other systems from there and then I
moved on to the PC for a while okay okay
94 I got a 486 PC games and then
upgraded again three years later to like
you know AMD k-6 yes 3d cards it started
pretty early dabbling in the PC what
what made that a transition for you to
go from console or PC kind of fairly
early yeah was early I think it was
actually like doom doom and Nukem 3d
like seeing that stuff on the way like
dudes like 95 or 99 t6 but those first
person shooters man like seeing that
stuff running I played doom in
somebody's house yeah just like it was
over that puzzle I had to play it did
you look at the consoles at home like
it's just not gonna cut it but like I
still I still love the console games I
love the platformers and such it was
awesome but uh you know just it was the
the PC really drew me in with you know
his first-person shooters and then like
LucasArts adventures that was really
being here
and like drawing back in the day I did a
lot of cartoon stuff so like you know
playing stuff like day the tentacle Sam
and Max okay I love that stuff
those resumes nice continue Oh sir okay
so from there I mean you know it was
lots PC yes once we got to my second PC
I started really getting into building
my own I guess you could say catching up
greeting cards you know nice ughter
shows which is like about the nerdiest
thing you could do I love the tech tech
I could relate back early I was getting
into I got like a power VR card first
[Music]
matrix M 3d which was like a matrix
branded power VR card and I'm you know
you know unreal with that little burst
unreal dude it was awesome at the time
yeah those games man that was that was
like my formative years I mean I got a
PlayStation and Saturn in 1998 okay so
it was late to the to that party and I
did enjoy so it was kind of weird you
know the consoles were very Japanese
focused yes I appreciated like end of
the Gees and like Japanese games on that
side but then for the real tech it was
more on the PC you know absolutely no
half-life you know sin there's just all
of that stuff happening so I was what I
would do is I would get a mark
oh yeah it sit there with my 3d
benchmark and tell my friend look how
shiny that ball will put the graphics
card in to be like do you see the ball
of your shine here and it's spinning a
whole lot better this time I totally did
that stuff I love those little tech
demos in like the benchmarks like 3d
Mars 3d mark 99 or 2000 we had like that
matrix
so when you got back you said that up
you kind of picked up and came late back
into the parties for his council as far
as uh presentation but what for saturn's
room he drove me back in uh so I was
always a big Sega fan so mostly you know
I played a lot of Super NES back in the
day but I was more into the Genesis a
lot of Sega games you know I loved their
arcade games man like that so it was
like 94 I guess that introduced me to
the world of 60 frames per second it was
Daytona USA I saw that for the first
time in arcade like you know 60 frames
per second was on consoles before right
because of the 2d side-scrolling games
they're all 60 but for 3d I'd never seen
anything like that before so I solved a
toner running in an arcade and I just
like stood there looking at it like how
the heck is this even possible like this
is unbelievable look a mess and that
happened constantly like I realized I
was pretty lucky cuz an arcade near us
just they kept getting in all the
leanest Sega games that was a m2 back
indentation yeah they've old it man
I still think like Virtua Fighter 3 is
like oh my god gorgeous technology has
history I mean like the the leap to what
it was doing create from everything else
on the market it was like night and day
it was like we were seeing a future
right there
absolutely King man we could take me
back loading them because I remember
going to you know those arcades with
King and like I said we're Tekken fans
oh that's good talkin to ya we got I
have to give Virtua Fighter so I'm so
glad you said that because I remember
seeing VF 3 and just remember solve we
were like blue line and once we saw the
the Dreamcast version that's when we
just like fell over like they did launch
through what a trifecta it was scarred
racer yeah
and it scut race which never came to
console ever no yeah I wanted that game
so bad and that a virtual fight is three
when we saw virtual fighters three that
day never forget it it was like I sent
chills up my spine and I said they want
big is back it's like let me say you
know it the technological jump at that
times I believe at that time they even
do a fabric and just emulsion and oh man
it was like they did like inverse
kinematics you guys know what that is
break it down right essentially we're to
put it simply it's how they are able to
calculate the way legs intersect the
geometry so like you notice the steps
piles of dirt there's like a slanted
roof different things and they had this
thing where they could calculate how the
character should be standing on
differences in space I think that's the
first game I ever saw that in action
where it really looked like the
characters were placing their feet press
around
absolutely I completely remember that
it's so funny it was those very small
like kind of those details but again
prior to that that had not really been
done and on yeah so you're absolutely
right okay yeah that's a big one did you
also say they shouldn't got you to come
back into the era so what were some of
those Asian games it's not even so what
happened was I was really into PC and
then I start seeing the Dreamcast
announcements or whatever like the first
thing I did is I went and got a Saturn
goodness for that cuz I came in late in
the Saturn so I got a lot of games for
like real cheap upgrade of RAM card for
the back mark a perfect Capcom games no
I didn't I don't have any of the RAM
card games actually I really want to get
us three fighters gyro three No
man the price the price on that I wasn't
yet I have my import library is huge now
I'd like 250 Saturn games but just just
from Japan when I was collecting just
American games back then because that's
what was local right right absolutely
right but along the way I also basically
inherited a Playstation from a friend of
mine who's like cuz it stopped working
you had to turn it upside down to make
it work so I figured out that you just
opened the thing up and you can adjust
the laser potentiometer okay you know
it's not gonna help your system live
long but you adjust that strength a
little bit and it starts reading again
so your friend that thought he didn't
work he bought a new one he bought
another was like upside down did we even
know that like I knew about the trick
too cuz I started doing that first and
it was like alright it works but then
it's almost like those on those weird
findings with fixes for consoles like
even with the NES with like who thought
of like okay if you blow the cartridge
that had a chance it's so weird like how
these desperation you know inspiration
in the gaming nation forms us to do wild
way I got all that info where I got all
that info was like going to like J&L
games and penguin village and talking to
the guys behind the counter because
they're dealing with this stuff all the
time
oh yeah there's no internet like so if
we're discussing this stuff amongst
ourselves trying to figure it out so
that that was my source like we'd go
with him like man this is not working
you have any anything going on oh yeah
we've done this that and the other in
the store and then that that information
just gets disseminated among Smith
gamer's and that's how we figured all
that stuff out like dub yeah that's
everything I got from penguin village
and Elizabeth Street was the paperclip
mod the eraser so many weird things back
to David continued a little bit about
the I will say this though that the
Saturn I got back then still works
perfectly rock-solid and new system this
Saturn's a great that old place I don't
use that one I use a different one but
that one does actually still work it
just skips a lot on the videos you know
I mean I'm just saying you know so from
there was like playing Saturn and
PlayStation and I got Metal Gear Solid
and you know didn't look amazing
compared to what was on the PC but I'd
never played anything before cinematic
in that way yes and I was completely
just blown away by what they did was
that I couldn't even believe but the
whole time play and I kept thinking man
this would look so good on I was always
like telling my friends like do you see
you think this is cool just wait till
they do this on casting did you use the
bloom cast I did mess with the bling
cast and that's yeah that's interesting
[Laughter]
for me then Dreamcast type I was you
know are still playing PC and some of
those consoles but I was really excited
for Dreamcast
you know leading up the launch I was
going to stores and playing at the demo
kiosks whenever I could you know I
wanted to import it but it was hundreds
of dollars at the time to do that you
know be looking at spending a grand it's
just oh yeah yeah I couldn't do that
back that new way [ __ ] was
important yes listen every system
mentioned I imported every system I had
a super graphics yes that's how crazy I
was I forgot the name of it but it was
it was like a piece our and there was
just the piece BFX and they only had
like six games um and I'd probably
taught myself Japanese to be honest with
you during our whole favorite game yes
that is so freakin awesome man I'm a
little jealous that you get I would we
were big on that because um we were
lucky at coming in from New York we had
a lot of local importance that we would
go to yeah they would have literally
like you know PlayStation all these
systems a year before American release
and the only thing yet the learn was
figure out like some type of a
translator and then get you to either
the X in the circle button being
reversed from a confirm and backup they
know it thing on the controller but um
once she got past that it was it was the
same so it was like we just couldn't
wait we needed to see what the new tech
was gonna be before it came to this that
is amazing just keep going super
graphics no actually I don't know sadly
I I wanted to do this the museum thing
because like you have a Saturn I still
have my Saturn I have purchased me a
Dreamcast off of ebay I purchased an
original GameCube the Panasonic one I
love that one the middle one whoo yeah
that's awesome
yeah oh I try to go back and get these
systems back but at that time you're
younger so when the new system comes out
I go right down to the the little shops
of my pop shops sell my old systems to
get the new ones take it it would be no
trading deals yeah yeah no idea and I
traded in some stuff as well back in the
day to get like new video
kourt's yeah again cake was too bad
because even we got to experience like
Neo Geo because of him
Oh ink cartridges but they were arcane
perfect them you know they we had like
the I remember seeing it for the
turbografx-16 CD first because of him
and NASA's like an arcade perfect
fighting Street member fighting she the
first one before with food fighters
because it was fighting Street on
internal grab and the CD yeah just to
hear the audio that I regret so much now
like I let's not worry about how many
sealed copies of Panzer Dragoon saga I
had in my possession I don't it's
painful to think about it's really bad
that's that's the life you know the life
was you had to trade up to get higher
like so you know I found an outlet there
was selling neogeo games launch like
when he came on arcade they also came
out there so the games was $250 and just
the cars he would be able to trade in
your old cartridge and then give you a
hundred dollars but the sad part is okay
I get a hundred dollars I paid 250 I
lost 150 dollars but then I would see
that same cartridge summer for 225 and
his store and I just look at him like
this guy is robbing me anxious to be in
the Dreamcast you're really high pick it
up on launcher did you get it later
definitely law I got on US launch of
course picked it up with Sonic Soul
Calibur and blue stinger good dude and
then so yeah man that I played Soul
Calibur first when I picked up the
system and just mind-blowing at the time
absolutely absolutely
remember that launch lineup like this
great man that soul calibur okay perfect
I mean ah they had so 2 K series so many
good
games man yeah the 2k series was a huge
thing the NFLPA looked unbelievable at
the time ready I'm just gonna say that I
arcade perfect Hydra Thunder yes
absolutely
that was probably in console history one
of the best launches as far as content
for games that we have had like it's the
triple-a across the board was insane
insane before they said that King
because I had a conversation head off
the lowest thing in the nlg guys and he
had to remind me oh geez be like the
launch titles available it was so strong
[Music]
yeah yes you kept going so obviously I'm
assuming we have all the current gen
systems and all that good stuff so
that's good but now I want to get into
like now what kind of got you to where
you are as far as even leading to
digital foundry and also Eurogamer so
how did that come about come about like
what led to what oh man that's a that's
kind of a weird one uh so I worked in
like IT programming that kind of stuff
for like
more than a decade a while like you know
when I was living in the States that's
what I was doing you know I worked in
the automotive industry is doing these
computer stuff essentially I got to
travel though get went and lived in
Tokyo for a bit I was gone Oh up in
Detroit some you know just in various
spots but it kind of you know just kind
of went along and I guess I got married
in 2010 mm-hmm and my wife is French so
eventually in 2013 but it was kind of
like you know oh yeah thanks so she was
like you know kind of want to go back
it's like it's I you know it's kind of
open to it and right here with her job
you know she's a chemical engineer so we
traveled off her job I saluted lady of
the realm
so I basically quit my job completely I
just say well I guess I'm done yeah
[Laughter]
that's what I did okay
I came to Europe and just at that time
we actually moved to France first now
I'm in Germany I was just like Richard
was looking for somebody to help out
essentially sit on the page I thought it
was a good opportunity to try something
that I was more passionate about back up
one second cuz again for the uneducated
now Richard digital foundry existed as
an entity or ready and which was kind of
running that right I'm just confused as
all right yeah yeah yes so Richard's
been around doing game related stuff
since like 1989 Wow some are like wait
you read better love that voice in the
States he's not that well-known because
obviously the magazine's didn't come out
there but in the UK he was like a
household name like he was doing all
kinds of magazines like it's it's pretty
much like the equivalent of like you
know the top EGM guys or something okay
like so one of it like very well-known
in England like did a lot of magazines
he did started he's mostly Sega focused
so it's stuff like mean machines he did
the official Sega Saturn make kind of
stuff you know they even he was the one
that helped orchestrate the
one of their issues that [ __ ] came with
the first disc of Panzer Dragoon saga
with the magazine yeah but yeah so he at
some point which was that more like a
DVD related thing like I mean like DVDs
for like magazines and uh strategy guys
and such okay and then back because it's
almost like a packing some a lot of
magazines had that packing disc and I
remember look so that was kind of a
thing at that time
you know went away the internet even get
our demo discs and stuff from those
magazines exactly exactly
so it's pretty much I mean he started
about as far as I can tell like this
first Eurogamer articles you guys
remember those where he wouldn't it's
like compare like six or seven games at
a time but it was just like a blurb or
two and like a test it just started as
that and then he started doing more and
more and he brought on some other guys
and you know it just kind of grew and I
was an avid reader of that at a time so
when it came when there was an
opportunity to kind of do something like
that since I really enjoyed that stuff
I'd basically like threw my hat in the
ring was lucky enough to get a shot to
kind of test myself a nice and low aka
Lord let me kill that interview it's
kind of a test even I had to do two
tests kind of look at a game and try to
break it down like we would do and it
was in Crysis 3 because that was the one
that was just hitting at the time and it
was like all right that's a good good
one to look at but you know when I
started there we were pretty much just
article based right like for the first
two years all I did was write articles
and you know do some screenshots and the
frame rate videos were just like short
videos and no voice over or anything oh
and then and 2015 we started a push to
do more like what we do today and I was
I think my first videos were that I did
with voice was did one on Xbox streaming
on the PC
and years of War Ultimate Edition was
the first big comparison to I did okay
so ever and that thing took me like jeez
like a week and a half to produce yeah
yeah I do I remember that one actually
to the quality that's one thing you guys
over there very high quality on your AP
notes that that was a good that was a
big one that's big that wasn't big no
that was I love I love me some gears so
I say that was kind of like the learning
game for me figuring out how to do the
video stuff and it just kind of kept
evolving from there yeah she said then
it went from now let me get the ahh
it started from kind of like writing
your game and then you kind of then
transition into the video production
side and kind of lean more into digital
foundry because they're they're one
entity right I'll just break it down
from you is it one single entity under
your agreement umbrella or their
separate sort of we're stuff there for
the tech stuff but we're kind of our own
thing
gotcha so not we're not one in the same
but we are you know connected to those
guys of course there's a lot of cool
folks working over your gamer down so
Eurogamer salute digital foundry Richard
Ledbetter huge fan oh oh he's like I
said me and me and soft laugh all the
time like he has the most illustrious
voice breaking down technology it's it's
it's fantastic obviously like a lot of
us older gamer Lawrence we survived that
8-bit dude 32-bit console wars we all
try to have all the critically acclaimed
games that come out as we possibly can
but obviously now with the intensity of
the current console wars right like how
did you ever envision digital foundry
becoming what it is because in my dream
is like it's like the post of modern
gaming culture like everybody waits for
that digital foundry breakdown whether
it's a you know an Xbox with X versus a
ps4 parole you know 60 frames per second
resolution or whatever the budget on the
side of the fence you're on you wait
with either anticipation or fright
and I know did you found you're about to
make that video I'm like they better set
the world on because its balance
breakdown but it's just so precise
hey like I said if you're looking for
for a title or you actually let's say
you have all platforms and you're
deciding which to get and you want to
see them you know the advantages and
disadvantages on each it's such a cool
thing so did you guys ever envision like
it would become this I mean you guys are
the pulse of gaming culture right now
that's that's so weird to think about
when you say it that way all of it it's
my house doing this stuff you know
trying to make interesting entertaining
videos that's like yeah you know it's a
it's a it's a crazy thing but I mean I
enjoy doing it for me the main driver
really is actually to uh I have a lot of
friends that that are developers in
games and you know I developed a lot of
software myself but not actually games
like other software but uh I know how
much work it takes to build this stuff
like I haven't experienced anything
quite as intense as like a crunch crunch
period or something on a game mind you
but you know I like to celebrate what
these guys are doing so I kind of view a
lot of the videos it's like you know
it's it's part comparison when there's
multiple versions but also like a big
part for me is just kind of highlighting
the hard work that these guys put into
this these games you know like hope
people appreciate ya like why this stuff
is so cool why does it and why you
should care cuz you know reviewers
they're just gonna talk about all well
the game is good bad whatever the
gameplay the story that stuff and I feel
like you know it's it's the artists and
the the programmers and all the other
guys you know doing this stuff in the
background that I want to try to try my
best to you know give them some extra
like shout outs you know some credits to
showcase like the good work that's done
you know it's not done well I'll point
it out of course but you know I I kind
of prefer to be more positive than
negative
I've noticed that the reason why I
gravitate to the channel is because one
is not biased right it's just facts well
you know I know everything
so and the breakdown of these facts the
wise and the house and this is what you
should be looking for like when you see
this and you say like certain terms that
I'm not well-versed in with Lord Cognito
is well versed in or Lord sovereign is
well versed in and I see these terms so
I'm able to have a conversation with
these guys about what I've just seen
with your channel make me more
knowledgeable going into the
conversation a widowed distillation was
off on the air
and let me explain why I just love how
lit they make Twitter's that's off Big
Love is I mean I love all the tech
breakdowns of the modern stuff but for
me it's the df' retro it's to my heart
in a way that like it's stuff that I
would love to be able to do myself and
it's just because apart from you
breaking down like a specific game or in
the history of that it's a history
lesson in it of itself and that's what
that's the what I love most about it
because you know you'll break down like
for instance doom like doom you took
every single version of that game and
explained why it was different why it
was special why things were different
and at the same time you're explaining
sort of the the the culture around
gaming at that time to sort of
understand how these different
differences came about is it's you
attack it in a way that shows how much
love and reverence you have for this
stuff that I love it I mean I've noticed
that you guys put up that that the I'm
sorry to cut you off the UH no good XD
press conference thing this morning yes
oh my god just to sit there and just
listen to you guys talk through that
stuff and and obviously you see
everything in 20/20 hindsight yeah see
like where where the vision was then and
where things are going I love that stuff
I just love looking at stuff like that I
appreciate it very much
thank you very much cuz yeah the richer
stuff is like my own passion project
that's the stuff that I love doing the
most it comes across it comes across you
can feel yeah
I mean my thought transition right into
the question have you for Rachel because
um obviously like you we also know you
as the ambassador for that you know I
mean I mean and like what I like what
you do is similar what's obviously is
that you guys almost do like what you do
specifically which is great is you put
people in the time capsule of what was
going on during the creation of that
console yeah yeah that's what I try to
do do you got that on smash there's no
one beat you on that like I remember
what I was doing I remember the climate
of the game in the industry and then
sometimes you don't take a franchise
what you'll do is you'll have the
evolution and every iteration of the
game on different platforms and just to
see the growth kind of to like when it
comes now like Tomb Raider you did that
before and it's just such a nice touch
and a celebration and and like you said
before like it's about giving credit to
the dead what was the thought process
behind them to choosing these verses now
you know that kind of thing you know you
kill it with that man it's iron Lords
saluting for that like I love the retro
series fantastic job oh man that's so
nice to hear cuz ya you you guys are
exactly getting what I'm trying to do at
least somewhat successful there watch
when the videos pop up on my youtube fee
which is probably I don't know I've
turned into this weird guy that YouTube
is actually my information highway it's
like my goal to like when I be
compressed from the world I go straight
to YouTube so normally you guys are
pop-up and then weird stuff that they're
recommend and I'll go straight to
watching that video even if I don't have
any thoughts of purchases in that game I
want to see the comparison and the
breakdowns in to why because and that
directly goes into that the Chinese
system all the thing that Richard did
yeah yes yes and I was intrigued by it
when I saw them talking about how many
cores it had and all this other stuff
and then to see that you actually
got the system in-house and the size of
the system in the build of the system
but it actually is running as like a PC
opposed to a console but I said I posed
a question yes and I said well maybe
they view consoles the way we view PCs
and it's their view because we don't
live in their culture so it has Windows
10 on it and maybe their boot up and
stuff like that is of console their self
but it's dis powerful and I saw the
games that were playing on it and I said
wow it just took me to something that I
can't access right now and you guys gave
me a window into something that I was
very curious about and I was
appreciative that you actually did that
you guys actually think the time I to
get that system to do that oh yeah I'm
so glad that was possible to do that
because I I don't know the whole process
but I don't think it was so super easy
to get well richard has it at the moment
so I want to check it out next time I'm
over there actually I do have a quick
question for you was there any
particular project that you did that
blew up a lot more to your expectation
where you was like wow I didn't expect
that well let's see okay so there's
there's two I guess is one is that we
did that thing on the ps3 conference
earlier this year three was talking
about it right yeah I was just like I
hate it sounds fun to do it I didn't
expect like anybody to watch it but that
video keeps coming back people keep
watching it and like alright that's cool
let people like that one I think I think
that as part of the retro series is
perfect because again a lot of our
memories okay you know it you look back
then memories of those events right back
then we it was hard for us to actually
watch these events right we got the news
coming out of it if you weren't at an e3
you'd be able to get that afterwards so
all of the excitement around the tech at
that time or all the rumors and although
this is like with the ps3 you can have
to you know get another job or whatever
all that stuff like it puts you back in
that moment and how you felt like you
were pissed off or like you
were elated and it is just the fact that
you can sit and discuss that stuff now
with all that hindsight it equal parts
educational and hilarious to do really
quick that finger up you guys shout out
to Lord sandwich over one of our editors
for the TSE Jen website he said thanks
for the ton of work that you do guys
like you do John and following since in
since 2012 always enjoy your tech
breakdowns it's one of the reasons he
began studying engineering
oh yeah inspiring man in the room that's
awesome
Rhode Island make no mistake oh well
it's gonna ask you to transition on now
obviously you know obviously Microsoft
for majority Lords here you know myself
kind of our preferred platform in around
we have everything but obviously we do
like Xbox but um now can you tell us
what led one of the biggest exclusive
check reveals ever in my opinion by
digital foundry which was the Xbox one X
and at that time just you know put us in
a place you know you guys were kind of
allotted that ability to go behind the
hood before anyone you know and get a
chance to see that text so break down
that whole process and then just you
know that the Scorpio chip said you know
that whole thing and getting under the
hood and down and dirty with the Xbox
one X oh no that's a little tricky one
I'm not actually sure how how much I can
talk about whatever you can download a
few please do but if I we don't want to
get you in trouble but as far as just
just the experience itself like getting
your head can you talk about just saw
how you know how you felt like putting
it through its paces or some type of
benchmarking or just just the
opportunity alone kind of blew my mind
and it was a man like okay I have this
question that what kind of thought press
did you have when you found out that you
guys bore doing that yes I was just like
wait what
that's how I felt when they said we were
having you today right all right because
it was we have a chat right and in that
chat um it's like what we're going to do
for the weeks to pretty much our last
week I had a question yeah well I had a
topic that I didn't use and I'm really
passionate about this topic and so I
said you know we can cut that um last
week because we had to guess on and I
didn't want to go over I said I'll save
it for next week so you know and I'm in
a chair and I said well you know my
topic is the same as last week I just
you know want to spy on that and then
they said well the guest is you it was
like you know linked is Twitter check
out his Twitter you'll get well-versed
if you're not well-versed and I'm like
hold up this is what a cold sweat hittin
and I said I don't want that freeze
moment with you like well you know
question in the lake but I'm pretty sure
that was your same moment when they were
like okay well we're gonna talk about
the X and uh and your globe safe digital
facts
yeah we're gonna go live with this later
you said you just randomly wake up is a
digital foundry you're revealing them
not just you don't have dissected
never-failing that was like yeah why
Microsoft letting another company reveal
they don't I thought it was genius
because they understood exactly how
important you guys were yes with so many
people in the industry that could do
something like that on a positive effort
like no it's not even that adding is the
fact that they are the goal to you
understand like when you this is how
confident this is this is what I took
from it right um they were so confident
in the Texas they were about to reveal
and this has been unprecedented to give
it to a third party to do that dissect
that is they what it is that she choose
to say about it
without you know Stan well you can't see
this you can't say I don't know for sure
but I thought it was supreme confidence
in them and knowing that they know your
audience then your audience will like
tune in facts and how big you guys are
when it comes to that like a game being
so confident they released they review
copies a month are absolutely right
we're just like you know the hardware is
just really good so I mean we could say
whatever we wanted about it honestly
there is you know in the cosmos space
they just did a fantastic job with it
it's a great machine absolutely and in
like King said and reading with accent
you know for me when I heard like I said
I called you guys you guys are the page
that you guys have the pulse of gaming
modern culture down you got shot with
your finger on the pulse so to me I felt
it was a fantastic move by Microsoft it
showed just like King said complete
confidence because make no mistake if
your tech is being put presented in
front of digital foundry it's going to
get broken down then will be no you guys
go through the reference of checkerboard
but was it true that when your article
went live your site crashed because
there's so much traffic because that's
what I heard oh you know I can't
remember but I feel like that might have
happened or at least it was like really
really slow for a short period cuz I
remember people's like the articles of
us I'm waiting for that video I'm not
was it up to long afterwards but it felt
like that 10 minutes was a long time is
that like they were so inadvertent you
guys because of all the tech breakdowns
that happen at the beginning of the
console of this generation 2013 with the
Xbox one and bass ps4 and like all the
the comparisons that you know resolution
gate and all that stuff that you guys
were sort of like inadvertently kind of
in the middle of because of your tech
analysis yeah it was just I thought it
was genius on that particle right back
to that source and say you know what
here you go guys you know only two but
it's uh you know we'd already like with
the ps4 Pro like that kind of stuff got
out there right so we put these stories
about the specs and ahead of time so I
feel like it's it's it's almost you know
if we can just get it official word from
the mouth certainly see it directly it's
like kind of clears up the potential for
hairs there bro stuff it's like you know
you have to go from what you have and
it's like if if something appears worse
in those documents than the reality you
know that can't you gotta clear it up
right so yeah I can see the benefit but
you know if you're gonna do that with a
with a group like us I guess you know we
got to be confident the hardware that it
was ultra great confer and like the one
thing you just nailed it a good point to
is that you know by having that you know
as opposed to the pro situation where is
a lot of inferring right you guys a sit
there based on home inspection you can
only do so much as far as you know what
you guess but it's really cool how'd you
guys break it down and and then when the
axe came and then it's located we don't
really have to do any more inferring we
have it here
where you know Mike's office let's go do
it put it through the paces and see the
stuff and I remember that a Forza
horizon you know that the the that for
summarize when a Forza kind of expect
them or something that they was showing
you guys at the time
and it was just fantastic and you guys
are like hey it's only utilizing you
know this percentage of you know the
Xbox one X is not really all the way
optimized yet and it's really
fascinating stuff just to see you guys
break that stuff down so yeah salute
that you got tremendous job tremendous
job with the Xbox one ex you know
coverage I thought that was a fantastic
get for digital foundry I thought it was
again complete confidence by Microsoft
in the tech and it was cool to see that
whole thing kind of enfold with you guys
and definitely something to the team for
that that's cool and thanks yeah it was
uh you know I I'm I'm kind of glad to
see the competition come back into space
like this as well like you have all
these console manufacturers like vying
for you know your dollar it's like
Microsoft being on top of the world of
360 is what led to the original Xbox one
you know they were just too confident in
what they had going on and there's this
Don Mattrick
because I say this this is the greatest
era so far I must say all right mom and
I tell people every day that Microsoft
is the baby that we never want it and
it's because that Sega died so Microsoft
actually you know stepped into those
shoes yeah I'm not saying it because the
system is a dark color system I have
absolutely no idea but it filled that
void where we wanted it to be say go we
always what if we can take the name and
put it on the box and and be successful
and Sega yeah we'll be happy those kids
that don't know that just Microsoft kids
these are the original Sega kids we're
here for that and now seeing that
Microsoft has grown into this entity
like you said with the 360 and they got
the hubris that had them believing that
they can do anything and anything that
was on impotent and we will follow no
matter what then they fell flat on their
heads and to see the reversal but it was
still in technological the commercial
success for them having the ether
the the hard drive they set the tone
Xbox Live debuted with LG right where
they flat on the heads you know
yeah the messaging was mixed and they
thought they can do anything they could
recover from anything what happened was
when they put their games out and
digital they said he didn't understand
the digital foundry but we're gonna do
break down what was actually happening
and y'all got part of this movement this
wave this this culture without being
biased at all just stating the facts and
this game ones at 1080p and this ones at
ninety I 900p was like my BAE like I had
a responsible for the X even exist we
gotta get everything turned around man
we get hit at every quarter let's make
it was the interest the previous gen
there you go back and old comparisons it
was pretty flexible 360 trouncing the
ps3 was I don't think they they really
wouldn't they made that I don't think
they thought it was that effective back
then but see the reason they didn't know
that is because it was reversed their
PRT but then when it was reversed again
he's like man I bet you Microsoft said
one pointer time this last decade the
thing that sucks is like you know the
community latches onto whoever like the
winner and loses loses like during the
Microsoft there was like ODF only likes
Xbox it flips around for the next gently
all the only into Sony they don't like
anything else
that's where I sympathize with you guys
because you know with every positive
thing you may say about Xbox one you
know and every positive things you know
the other side will always accuse me oh
well you know they had exclusive rights
to the PlayStation sign and it really
shows you know how something is but even
with the spider-man thing that broke the
internet right I was actually did the
spider-man thing because I played it at
e3 and to hear the negative that they
were saying could the puddle thing a
puddle gate what did you think before
you do any analysis or anything on the
puddle gayson area well by the time it
popped up on my feet I was already
playing the game I was just like guys
like if you actually see this thing
running and play it it's like it looks
awesome like what the funny thing is
people in this community actually pretty
much started the puddle guy I think I
think the Lord Kofi literally started
the puddle because they know I like Xbox
but let me tell you something this was
my game of the show like Spiderman was 3
and I said I did I said if you get a
chance to touch it if you see it
my thought was hey I'm always jaded by
the Final Fantasy demo that they showed
and we never actually got their game
remember when he was dancing in a ball
yeah that's when we learned the horrors
of vertical slice demo so I saw the the
CGI which I thought was CGI for
spider-man at the time when they showed
us oh there's no way the game goes hey
the game really does good on that CGI to
actual gameplay the transition between
cinematics and the game are the
cinematics are real time yes real time
yeah you can pause at any time and like
mess around with the colors in the field
and like manipulated all you want and
it's just they do that awesome job of
transitioning
between cinematics and gameplay orlova
spider-man has never made it so easy to
make thumbnails in my life because this
was the day we're talking man later
before they were like you know peoples
of reference part of it that you know
your statement in reference to that
there was no downgrade as opposed to an
artistic change no do you stand on that
Square still like do you are you are you
letting the fanboys know the nicely no
doubt lady I think people have
misunderstood when you say artistic
change they they they think oh they just
change it because they thought it looked
better it's like a lot of times in this
case like I think the East rebuttals
kind of looked better and I said that in
the video because the reason I think
they change it is has to do more with
the amount of work required because it's
not there's not really a technical
difference between how the III and the
final game turns out maybe a slight
difference in the resolution of the cube
map the whole thing centers on those
reflections use something called a cube
map you know essentially a box projected
texture beneath the surface that's
designed to sort of like it's just a
picture of the scene and you put them
all to the surface right right so that's
you can kind of fake reflections that
way and you know if you look closely at
the texture you see it's not accurate it
doesn't reflect the objects but to do
that all over the game world in an
open-world game you know they're already
using a lot of cube maps that's it
that's a super time-consuming thing so
honestly my guess is they just found a
way to do puddles and water in a way
that's more like efficient for their
time so it's a art change in the sense
that it's a change to make the game
easier to to create like a more
efficient way to do it like making all
these custom textures specifically for
these rooms like that's a that's a ton
of work right there right I feel like
there's solution in the end it's just
more like you know it's again this is my
guess I haven't actually talked to these
guys yeah I think it's easier for them
to do it right and I'm not to say like
everything they've done like very
difficult work clearly like there's a
ton of effort went into this but
absolutely the whole reason the
situation bothered me in the first place
is nothing to do with the console wars
or anything like that I just thought it
was disrespectful to the to the guys
that worked on the game
thank you it doesn't show it shows a
lack of understanding of what it took to
make and it shows a lack of like you
know empathy in terms of like what they
had to do to make this work and like
what you have to think about when making
a game and not understanding that when
you're doing these vertical slices for
an e3 demo I was like that's all you're
doing you're focusing all this time and
effort into perfectly polishing up this
little bit of gameplay
it's just show off and it's like you
don't know you haven't asked all the
questions yet that are great coming when
you're when you're reaching the end so
like as the development continues it's
like you suddenly realize oh we can't do
this for this reason and it's usually as
nothing to do with oh the system can't
run it it's other things there's no real
quick question go for it and I think
what it with this can it happens and
first of all fantastic points because
you are correct the lot of the gamers
casual game we do not understand the
decision-making process the technical
arm you know limitations or things that
are needed to make things happen and
we're you know as far as just to present
something to us now on the other side I
want to be fair and balanced on the
other side you know Lord King or
sovereign we've kind of old enough to
have been the ìiî in the past before and
when we see those quote unquote vertical
slices and like I said not to talk place
it on the bus but the kill zone is an
infamous you know even even watchdog
right and I get question you know in a
minute is that because gamers in the
past have quote-unquote I'm gonna say
full deceit but they've been misled as
far as what's being presented on screen
as we know sometimes it's a vertical
slice but then when they get home and
they like wait a minute this is not what
was shown I do at least maybe empathize
with the gamer on that level when
they're looking at absolutely absolutely
I just think it's a it's a situation you
can't judge with a blanket yeah go ahead
I think there's a difference between
someone being burned in the past and
someone using console whorfin at finish
to push the agenda more than that that's
what I see the most on Twitter it's it's
not about you know what's been done in
the past games like watchdog it's about
it's on PlayStation so I can attack it
fortunately but I think you know again
so with every game it's gonna be
different like we've since learned Ike
with Killzone right all that all that
was was an internal demo REO like that
was it had nothing to do with the actual
development of the game so like they
chose to show that on stage guerrilla
games we we purchased our videos and I
don't know how we got yeah I don't know
how we got this invite but we were on
their list and they send us the invite
to come down the Carnegie Hall to you
know trip Hawkins is the greatest
snake-oil what we were presented to was
a behind the scenes showing of the 3do
em to their expansion on the existing
existing 3do hardware to complete with I
believe PlayStation all that stuff was
coming soon I believe so what we saw to
this day was probably one of the most
outrageously outstanding tech demos I
mean the thing looks so good and
probably could put Forza horizon right
now to shame we would just like I've
seen some of those videos but I am
insanely jealous that you guys get to
see that you know and salute the trip as
far as they showed us love but from that
we were filled with so much guts the
result it did find out none of it was
true
we were heartbroken a they had us sit
down in a beautiful auditorium yeah and
we was presented with the greatest real
demo reel that I seem to this date it
was a car racing game that was insane
and it was on like this virtual highway
which the Texas was beautiful and it
ended with a car coming in the opposite
way because we got on the highway and it
was a swarm it was brilliant
we walked away we like you know he's up
there he's able to talk to us we're
talking with shaking hands really like
come on we're impressionable find out
they put it in toast this there's been
like five games released for em to
hardware right you say what yeah so that
hardware that was being developed was
picked up and used by Konami and there
are I believe five arcade games that use
the m2 hardware or offline we've got to
talk about this so one of the first ones
to look up is something called battle
tryst it's like a Artois st from Konami
it's the 1998 fighting game and that
game it's based on and so yeah there's a
few others as well but I think I think
it's called like Konami system 16 okay
no it's technically the m2 but it's uh
it is now he jumped in and kind of took
over as far as that the hardware or just
I don't actually know how how it came to
pass they like to sit out to everyone
like that thing we do we thought we were
the only people in the room and he was
talking to us he was talking everybody
was people that was there to purchase
this tech and I believe honestly that
you know he sold it because after that
we thought that the system was coming we
were ready for the next system and you
heard that it sold off and it was in
toasters yes
Oh too late I was our sorry for the
tachi but I didn't had no idea about
that that's fantastic 3do is interesting
I do plan to do D official on that and
the Jaguar oh yes but yeah we're works
for a while but we'll get there it's
interesting is it's like you look back a
lot of developers like really started to
take off they're like that's kind of
like Naughty Dog took off there right
that's what I said you know where Soria
and then insomniac games we talked about
spider-man I mean that's they started
working on 3do first their first game
which was disruptor was originally a 3do
game and like you know those guys were
we're working on that system and it just
seems like there's a lot of weird
connections that started from the 3do
that spiraled out into the crazy areas
absolutely what it what a crazy time
right oh yeah I love that time yeah
that's where this board so basically
obviously Oh John we know you as the
benchmark when a benchmark guys and you
are kind of known as the human fraps
so when did that obsession with
framerate start like wood frame pacing
and just breaking it like you are that
guy when it comes to framerate in this
generation how did that obsession start
that's kind of so that goes back to this
earlier story with Daytona USA is the
first things that made me say like okay
60fps and I went on a mission to get
that at home like how when I was buying
3d cards I was always looking it's like
they're just not as smooth as the arcade
it's not this isn't Daytona and that was
the obsession and it was a I think it
was when I finally got the Dreamcast and
started playing all those games again
and just seeing that it really kind of
hit home like how much that mattered
absolutely and somehow I just I'm just
really sensitive to like little
disturbances in the flavor force really
sticks out in my eyes like I can like
solve because I know I won't be able to
come back yeah literally I'm kind of the
same way way especially I'm a destiny
fan and I know what the PC guys are
doing I know myself
if I see that
level of fidelity as well as frame rate
it will make me not want to go back to
God the weird thing about that know is I
can deal with a lower frame rate as long
as it's consistent like my frames to be
delivered evenly we got you know I can
put up with 30 frames it depends on the
game you know for a lot of games 30 FPS
with motion blur looks good to me yeah
but it's gotta games it does yeah it's
it's it's generally good you know but
obviously you know higher is always
preferred but yes part of it though has
to do with the fact that you know it's
improving with different types of
techniques but when we moved to flat
panels
I killed the didn't kill it but it
reduced the impact of 60fps have you
guys looked at a CRT lately yeah yes so
you look at those old two televisions or
monitors and like the way motion looks
on that is so much so much so much about
you know any modern display absolutely
how good it looks like an old PC monitor
you play it like 170 Hertz or something
on that thing with thats perfect motion
and it's just it's ridiculous looking
and yeah that was that's the thing and I
really wish we get back there like we're
getting closer like there's a lot of
like neat techniques like you know black
frame insertion or the ultra lobe we
shouldn't blur those features that are
that are starting to get there but it's
still not quite the same jarring effect
like when we first saw the tobu 13
number two when we first saw that on
PlayStation and that's what we knew what
60 frames per second look like yeah it
was a flat shaded polygons but the
fluidity in the carriages and the speed
yes that's what we knew it was something
different like we understood at that
point in time we want more of this this
is what we want more of and just for me
reactionary and everything like that and
I even learned terms for me like you
know just frame pace and like I now
would make my eye more perceptive
because of you when I look at games and
I'm like yeah I see what he's talking
about now you know it's just the frame
pacing term is kind of a weird one I
think we just kind of came up with that
out of No
love it well you can call it all kinds
of different things I guess but it's
really just about like how long a frame
is persists on screen right right so
like if you have frames that are on
screen for variable amounts of time it
looks jerky that's really all it is and
you know that that whole frame time
thing was uh for awhile like nobody
really understood like what that was
about
so like you get this uh dual graphics
cards and SLI and the piece a lot of
those probes noise like my curse
stuttered and I guess basically what it
was it was just the frame from
persisting for different lengths of time
and it didn't look smooth even if your
frame rate was really high that was the
issue yeah absolutely I mean again great
great fantastic stuff there oh we got
now um I want to open up just a little
bit for the lords on Oh sod maybe I like
one or two before we move on and anybody
I mean for me I I'm really interested to
hear what you think about what's going
on just for the next consoles that are
coming down the pipeline I'm we're
probably about two years away from these
next consoles yes I mean it might be
closer than we think but um this past
week of this the CEO of AMD sat down
with Jim Cramer to talk about you know
sort of the turnaround of the company
and they she specifically mentioned
working with Playstation and an Xbox on
the the next iteration of the consoles
with Xbox specifically working on the
cloud stuff and whatnot but she used the
term secret sauce and it made me laugh
it made me laugh because it brought me
back to 2013 when all the stuff coming
out about the Xbox versus the ps4 and
the whole esram thing and people were
talking about that would be a bottleneck
and how they were supposedly the secret
sauce that it would use the esram in I
remember that with the X 12 X 2 million
and the cloud compute to sort of boost
up the power of the system so when she
uses a term like that like secret sauce
like what do you think that means
technically especially for looking
forward to these consoles like what do
you think is reasonable to expect from
these consoles coming down the pipeline
and what would you like
see and it's a secret sauce thing just
jargon hyperbole I mean I assume secret
sauce is just them finding a way to
accelerate some sort of operation that's
useful for games in a way that you know
you can do directly it's like extra
silicon to hopefully improve performance
in very specific ways that also
differentiates the box from the other so
like it's not identical machines I can
imagine like neither Sony or Microsoft
really want thee to have like identical
machines in the market so I mean I have
no idea what it could be or what they're
targeting what I'd like to see is
essentially what Nvidia is trying to do
right now RTX car it's like if yes I
don't know possible because it cost you
know but right RTX functionality it we
get a ray tracing in some console I
don't I don't think is these coming down
to pilot no I don't think that possible
especially do you think do you think
maybe a [ __ ] refresh of the next
console maybe maybe five years down the
line maybe can incorporate some of that
stuff oh I think are they're all weird
if it were mid June that would be a
problem I think cos you know starting to
in agree that this team existing
platform that just creates more of a
split than I think that I mean I feel
like that's the most exciting thing to
see would be retracing but I think it's
gonna happen so I would imagine that the
main push is just gonna be pushing more
in the direction we've been going like
better rasterized performance right so
we're hitting 4k resolutions more easily
yes I mean it's already impressive that
we've we've been getting a surprising
amount of native 4k games on the Xbox
one X as is yeah it's kind of it's kind
of impressive but I think it'll get you
know we'll get closer to hitting that
more often
yes but it's just it no no please finish
and then I'll follow up I'm just
wondering about the you know you see
this gap again with the PC stuff Nvidia
is pushing pretty
with some new technology and it's gonna
create this kind of gap and I'm very
curious to see us how that's gonna
impact the e the two going forward like
I'm almost wondering like is this gonna
limit the potential ray-tracing and
games anyway just because you know not
that it's from what I've heard it's it's
not that difficult to implement in terms
of you know it's a directx12 feature and
all that so you know it should be and
the stuff that we played I played a
bunch of r-tx stuff already at the
reveal event back at Gamescom and you
know some of those developers they were
just telling us like yeah we had like
two weeks to work on this on the
gardener and you know they implemented
some amazing stuff like that battlefield
stuff Oh fantastic
Andy how do you how do you think the PC
the PC gamers react to obviously that
being excited about the tech if you're
you if your first adopter you're gonna
jump on it regardless but the fact that
utilizing the tech at this point brings
down performance in a way that PC gamers
haven't necessarily been used to well
it's an interesting what I've been
thinking about I kind of feel like it
comes down to when you came into PC
gaming if you're an old-school PC gamer
you're gonna remember the days of no man
oh man like oh I can't wait to the day
when I can run at these settings or when
I actually get to this framerate like
actually push PC games for featuring
technology that was forward-looking like
stuff that you couldn't turn on when you
bought it like like yeah we could see
what that looked like but the hardware
just doesn't exist yet I think that's
what crisis was about and it was
exciting to like you know see each new
upgrade you know you're pushing further
closer and closer to your what you want
to see but in the last decade I feel
like PC gaming just become about well
just gonna ramp up all the settings and
the resolution of the Macs and it better
be perfect that's what they want that's
what they expect you're basically
playing you're playing console games
with some extra features yes some slight
boost it's just like boosting console
performance rather than like really
pushing into new areas low Coran it's
like if you came in during that period
then yeah I could see why
like that seems unacceptable to do it
but for me it's exciting but at the same
time it's you know I I I can understand
you know when they announce the price
stuff it's just like yeah you know it's
these things are expensive man so not
just I'm not gonna be for everybody yeah
it's the ground floor of the future and
when he's not there
it's disruptive in a way that's gonna
turn people off initially and it's gonna
go through a lot of growing pains but I
think ultimately we're gonna get there
maybe that's what the PC is for the PC
has always been the testing ground for
these growing pains to find out exactly
what works where and how to implement
that in a lower form in the consoles so
I always look to the PC so when they
sold the ray-tracing has been around for
a while but they are making it at a chip
level in the card so that is you know
it's gonna reach a lot of these games I
just want to see what games are gonna
take advantage of it and see if I'm
going to invest in said car yeah
absolutely
let me you are yeah I don't want to
interrupt it I just wanted to play one
more comparison is you know what what I
would like to see is so the original
Xbox used some sort of like variation
based on the GeForce 3 chipset but it
was you know it was a different thing
but that introduced programmable shaders
right yes a 4:3 was like I believe the
first consumer graphics card released in
2001 to support programmable shaders and
that's become hugely important to
graphics right and amazingly the Xbox
launched with that feature set yes and
you know it was early for shaders area
very limited compared to what we have
now but it was the start of something
and I feel like that really helps push
graphics forward in a big way because
you know the PC was improving and that
but the Xbox was still there so like
developers are maybe you're more willing
to invest in that you couldn't do those
things on a PlayStation 2 though the ps2
was very interesting in its own right
it's a really fascinating piece of
hardware but it's different that's why I
would have liked it you know again I
don't think it's possible but seeing
some ray tracing in the console would
remind me of when the
for three styles that nimpah mounted up
in the OG xbox is at this point the fact
that they're I think they both both main
console makers are dedicated to making
machine machines that are more like pcs
I think what you're saying is it
couldn't be more of a reality because
they're not really creating these super
like bespoke pieces of hardware that's
really that are very difficult to
program for all in their own right side
this should be fairly easy to program
for so yeah I mean my hope is that they
are able to to do something with this
tech and shrink it down and and and sort
of bring the price down within the next
couple of years so we can see this in
console gaming I would love that yeah I
think that I think the problem though is
like it's being introduced now and the
PC world and the consoles you know
likely already well into development and
it's late it's too late right yeah it
feels like it's too too late and too
expensive to really jump into the pool
right now it'd be awesome but you know
maybe maybe a Indies secretly working to
and I want to shout out Laura
korben Dallas in the chat who else she
was thinking along the same lines of B
which is we thought ours we told my spec
list a speculation is for us the
next-generation consoles and so forth
but like obviously the rumor more
secrets to our stuff is that Microsoft
is heading to what direction of maybe a
cloud-based system right where cloud
streaming technologies use and maybe
there's a device on the physical end
that kind of handles the input and
things that economy kind of like
generally detracting really you know
tripping as far as latency is concerned
so again I know this is speculation a
little bit I know this is rude but my
question to you is that you know based
on what we've heard like do you think if
anyone is capable of assuring that kind
of tech forward would it be Microsoft as
far as a cloud streaming system
oh I mean in terms of pulling that off I
think Microsoft is well positioned for
companies like Amazon or well-positioned
for us the ones that you know these guys
know that stuff there
networking they've got the money they've
got the hardware they've got the battery
lost AWS widowed I was mean exactly
silly they're kind of set up for it and
I you know it's a weird one for me
though cuz it's fascinating tech but
it's it's also kind of an assault on my
way of like yes so I'm not I'm not I'm
not that big of a fan of pushing in that
direction just because I don't want them
to take my disc's away but what was
presented was an option it's an optional
service and it stays that way that's you
know that's the key is it that it
remains optional it's a cool way to
maybe draw some people and especially if
it's like you bundled it in with your TV
yes
buy an xbox pad or something and your
body you know that's cool but it's it's
really it's not for me because I mean no
matter how fast you get you're never
gonna work the hard to perler latency
you never get the perfect image quality
it's the same reason why you know movies
I really care about I'm buying the UHD
blu-ray for a long time where it's all
you know streaming and I think the
reason of Microsoft especially wouldn't
try this is because I feel like they are
they have one mess up a whole generation
I don't think they want to start next
generation with another mess up because
2013 I honestly and truly think almost
cost and the Xbox brand I don't think I
think another one that caught the
generation right after it I don't think
they recovered it's a it's an
interesting one because a 2013 that was
an error I really that that turned me
kind of against the Xbox for a short
period because when they start talking
about that whole like game ownership
thing and they always online thing like
that and felt like I'm such a big
collector that felt like they were
basically telling me like now we don't
want to do things the way you want to do
it anymore and I was very afraid of that
becoming a thing that they are right
turn me way off of them for a while and
I will say they were like I got to hand
it to these guys the way they turn that
ship around man yeah I don't think
absolutely I don't honestly you know the
people I've met from Microsoft like you
know and Sony and Nintendo as well like
these guys it's a lot of really good
folks they're like really doing their
best they really care about this stuff
apps and but like rerouting your ship
like that when you have such a big
company navigate like changing that
direction the way they did that is very
it's like put a bomb on my own ship and
want it explode it's a little bit more
ambitious and a little bit more
forward-thinking day no it's kinky with
a pistol going for Microsoft isn't gonna
try to do like jumps like that for a
while
I think they're not gonna force it like
you said it's gonna be ops they're gonna
keep moving forward I don't think they
ever stopped being the ones that try to
push the industry forward I just think
they realized that the messaging around
it has to be very clear have to give it
has to be clear and have to give players
choice you know Philip said he said I
don't ever see a future where you don't
have a Microsoft an Xbox box in your
house whatever that may be so I mean
it's just a matter of how you message it
if we look back at 2013 a lot of the
stuff that they talked about that we
thought was cool is has come to light or
is in the process of coming to light it
was just a negative stuff around the
ownership that was there NORAD and and
the badness in Jing because no one truly
understood how these things work so it
created this fear like hey am I losing
Tony its own [ __ ] I love flies what you
don't say but he was at all
the video we this is how we really rub
from Mike I you feel like Don really
shouldn't have been like that was a PR
nightmare right there
like I'm sure the other guys at the
office where they see that they're like
yo someone got to talk to someone you
gotta go like that I thought was a lot
like there's like a burning City almost
like decay it's like my work here is
done
and I only lord it began with John or
the burning ship bad because I must tell
you this right some of the stuff that
Don has put into place man has come to
pass has benefited Microsoft maybe the
messenger was wrong maybe it was off
right and you know sometimes the way
somebody comes off you may not like his
approach so what they did was they put
in a different head coach and i'ma tell
you I mean some some people really say
all no Phil is to soften
okay to navigate like you said through
these shark-infested water you know I've
met Mike Ibarra I've talked to these
guys
salute to these real human individuals
you just you you you always have the
president or the face of the company and
if the face of the company
reflects the people that's under him
which are great people then you know
they're gonna lead to great things so I
honestly believe that everything that
they pointed to Don they probably didn't
like his approach whereas Phil's
approaches a little bit more strategic
but everything that was against them he
took off the board power narrative mmm
this way put the system in digital
foundries hands and let them present it
to the people instead of us presenting
it to the people so they can understand
that we have no control over that let
them say what they're gonna say and let
them you know dissect the system I
thought it was complete genius in doing
that so they can say we're hands-off and
whatever they say be mature listen to
them is right right okay so ho and we
listen and I think that's probably the
most I think I watched that video
probably at least once a month maybe
just that was the turning point that was
the point - aha moment when I said yeah
helps that Phil comes from luminoled
marks of studios to culture he's kind of
built his way through up as opposed to
you know someone kinda on the outside or
more of a corporate attitude or
what-have-you so it's just good to see
them turn around that thing in the right
direction we got a lot of shows we got a
move but of what the last thing on it
like soft got anything else is that um I
definitely wanted to get in as far as
the personal request from me was on
would you ever could one thing I think
you'd do great with d/f retro right I
would you ever consider doing like a DF
retro deep dive like on like the unsung
portables of the past because the
question the reason I brought it up is I
saw that video you did where he was like
hey you got your din tendo's with guys
you know you know - but did you brought
out the Genesis domain first like that
was amazing to me so would you ever
think of like doing like something on
the old portables cuz I that actually
was a huge fan of portables and I know
you said it was one of yours like I I
had the links you know I remember the
game I got a couple right here all mommy
and I don't I think you're the only one
kind of championing that the handheld
people don't realize the hand he'll hold
up a second let me just reach over here
let's go I got it I got my links right
here play the skateboard game get little
bit and now I won't ask you another
question
oh I was just gonna say so yeah I would
definitely love to do more that and the
only reason I don't do is so the
handheld stuff is tough first of all
dudes doing systems in general is tough
because you know it's just there's a lot
to cover but with handhelds there's both
the capture and the filming element so
you know like I did in that noob an
episode I had to film a lot of stuff and
since I'm a one-man show here you know
sitting all that camp doing all the
camera work like filming outside and you
know you know the different angles of
the system you know it just takes a lot
of time absolutely uh and you know I
guess I did film some of those systems
in that episode if I was I had footage a
game year and what's coming it's coming
but thing though is like to get those
camera angles looking good is like the
most uncomfortable thing ever tort your
arm is the weirdest way and I can barely
see the screen and you're just trying to
make it look like you're playing the
game casually but do we have to get the
Lord led bed on the phone
we got retro full segments full blow
outs old consoles the whole works man
life yeah I need to do I definitely want
to do more of those and like I said the
Jag and the 3do are certainly up on the
list those those will be the Jaguars
probably gonna come first some borrow
and a bunch of cartridges from from a
fellow very nice guy that is gonna be it
that cyber Morphin get the alien great
there's some great games on there and
there's also some really bad games
interesting mix
yeah let's keep pushing y'all we gotta
love to go as far as any wet it's good
good
okay guess on or like what much like the
the quest the prior question um in terms
of the Nintendo switch then well what
would you like to see in a switch 2.0
like like is Tegra 2 even still viable
or is there something out there too is
pretty yeah I don't want to know what
you want to see know so Tegra 2 is used
more in like automobiles it's not really
it's not really significant over the
regular tagar so what I would actually
like to see right now with the switch
cuz it's still relatively new is
essentially I want to see the super doc
I want a dog that you plug it into with
extra power I'm not sure work I'm not
sure if even the the connection between
behaves when that is even fast enough
it's like I do a lot to say that I don't
know about this but if it is I would
like to be able to plug it in and get
higher resolutions and maybe some better
performance you know just something to
spice up the doct experience okay and
handheld mode I still think switch games
generally look awesome
you know it's for for portable gaming
that's fantastic absolutely when you
talk it with your TV you know I'm with
you with you when you're playing when I
was covering the amazing ports of
Wolfenstein 2 and doom - the switch feel
like they shouldn't be possible but you
blow that up on a 65-inch for drops -
like 360p like that's why it you know
it's only for my portable purposes
because when I come home like you settle
I mean it's tough for me to throw that
in that [ __ ] when I have the Xbox one
next there the ps4 Pro you know it's
tough to be playing their version of
doom at home it just does their ducting
is great
if you look at what some people like
laptops are doing now with PC a lot
necessarily your you know desktop GP
used to it yeah mine though as Nintendo
does have a history of upgrade or right
yes Boy Color was just an enhanced
Gameboy the let's see that the DS had
the DSi which was slightly more powerful
I think and had a few extra features the
3ds had the new 3ds which had a
significantly faster hardware in there
and so they've done this stuff before
where they you know releases I must say
this view that system as a handheld no
they don't
it is not because they have a new coming
so yeah they really view it as a home
system now we might get a ram expansion
pack remember that for and that's the
only presidents that I can say that I
can look back and say ok they understood
what was needed and if it's the outcry
that's loud enough because the doc does
have that space in the back that
something should connect and fit in
there and I think it was
forward-thinking in saying that we can
do this later on because we didn't know
what the n64 when we opened it what was
go in there but they knew that's right
yeah I mean so that's what we got we got
push it on we definitely look behind but
on you know last being and then we're
going to the atopic stuff oh the name I
need to know this and we move on Dark
One X what is the science behind damn
day that's an old name from the 90s and
believe it or not it actually came from
a quake mod that I was working on I just
old dark and I was trying to make
something with using the the Reaper BOTS
that Steven posted and like somehow like
modify them and but put them in like a
much larger kind of map environment but
only put like two in there and it was
like a really dark map
the idea was like it was like you're
being hunted it sounds cooler in concept
than you know yeah but execution
execution cuz you know I didn't have the
skills to really change I you know I
just played around with some of that
basically sticking them in maps that I
made and I had you know it was just a
little bit of a oh good I dare even say
mod it was just making a map in the
stuff with that I drew some some
textures and stuff trying to you know
just messing around with that I did I
mess around a lot with the quake engine
stuff and duke3d the build editor I used
to make stuff into Nukem 3d but yeah
that's the name originates from that
okay and the the I think the X was just
the X was added just because like I
tried to join a forum and like the dark
one was taken or something I would come
off a whole new name before I had to put
numbers or anything in my name like but
every times like cuz gaming Atticus took
on xbox they're like just put like a
water to it no I was saying room to kill
before I go exact gave me headache
number eight okay so we work it we will
speak shout out the Lord of a color Dave
a color we added of Xbox Live we work it
on as far as xbox live gamertag
retention so it's coming soon we got you
attic without Oh glad you later god I
just thought the day was cool I was like
wait what's the story behind this like
this is a very it is a circa 1998 name
alright this is the last thing we put
although the this Lords a guest of the
realm on hot seat Lord liniment top five
video games or franchises of all time on
the spot digital foundry let's go oh
gosh I'm just gonna name some franchises
I think games but I might go with like
Mario Sonic hey
metal gear and just like a million other
things I could stick and it's just
almost like turning around something
like I don't know Mega Man because okay
what are the first people in Arizona in
one of the first you want to first
happen but I put those in though all of
those games or series like in the
various relations that I go back to and
I play a lot like I love those games I
played them all time Super Mario World
you know the classic Sonic games you
know the Halo games of course you know
all these games Mega Man like I don't
get tired of playing these games and you
know for that reason you know this stuff
I've enjoyed a lot as well but there's
just kind of stick out for me is like
the long term like I can go back here
and I always have a good time absolutely
fantastic list real quick on halo are we
going to be getting a breakdown of the
Master Chief collection 4k man that hit
it like the worst time because it always
comin out and then I have to do these
two shows and like you know England and
and Berlin and I've been playing it and
it's a so the the patch is interesting
because the main change is really like
it runs at high res and they had an HDR
didn't actually fix some of my
complaints mmm if you watch the halo
video I did on DF retro yes one of the
issues I always had with the halo 1 port
and Hale Irwin is like that's my jam
right there yeah that's what all all the
versions that came after the original
Xbox were like derived from like the
work that was done on the PC version
there's a lot of like visual glitches
and just things that aren't quite right
and that was hoped that they could just
like find a way to get it looking as it
should like you go into assault in the
control room you look up not course and
it's like black things sometimes be like
it's foggy like foggy looking sky and
the original Xbox but on this it's like
if it's fog and it just ends at a
certain point and it's like start black
and they just looks incorrect and it's
bright or you go to song cartographer
even on the new ones yeah obvious you
look at the horizon where the water
meets the sky and there's this big old
blue band that runs round the head but
this thing's like stick out it's just
like yeah hope to see all of that stuff
fixed but I understand maybe why it
wasn't I mean that's not it's not an
easy thing to address but still so it's
more of those minor details I don't like
also skybox kind of things or is it like
just it's a lot of like a lot of my new
show like that some of the effects look
great some of the way the textures work
you know things like that and it's
mostly halo one that's the issue and
it's activist so I get it gotcha
halo one has never been perfectly
replicated from its original Xbox form
guys so you know the you know the rest
of the pack pretty you know uh halo 4
has a lot bug where like stuff kind of
pops in rather than fades in like it's
supposed halo 2 anniversary looks
awesome but uh you know it has some
extra slow down I guess but overall
looks fantastic I like I don't really
like the way hailer one anniversary
looks the anniversary graphics but I
loved what they did for Halo 2 yes
almost because halo twos graphics
especially when you blow them up in high
res like the original graphics they do
they have an aged well they were trying
some new techniques and you know it was
cool at the time but it doesn't hold up
okay there was another but the the
remake that they did that's that's
awesome alright gotta just a question
quick attach had um the late look the
chatted talked about that mr. Adam II
said that you guys said that there would
be a DF retro on track one and two and
he's like we've never got it yet oh yeah
I can I can explain that okay so when I
wanted to do that one I was really
hell-bent on getting footage from a lot
of different 3d graphics cards like real
3d graphics cards and a retro PC the PC
versions supported because I think the
PC version is interesting so I reached
out to a friend who actually has all
that hardware cuz I don't I don't have
that much
your pc hardware right now at you it's
just difficult to store at all but uh so
he was helping me capture and it's like
it just you know he was going through
some life stuff and things were you know
difficult and I know he captured stuff
and then I haven't heard back forever so
it's pretty much just me waiting on that
and haha today I get it but if I don't
if I can't get it you know in the next
few months I mean I guess I'm just gonna
have to proceed without it but I really
wanted to do it that way with that stuff
to really show legitimately what it
looks like running on like the old ati
rage cards you know on 3d effects cards
on the rendition cards on the old and
new cards like just to give people an
idea of how all the cards varied so much
back then so absolutely shout out my
plans were big and but it wasn't your
fault though you waiting on someone we
didn't deliver a lord Chad stop stop
attacking gentlemen now stop talking to
Lord you know you need a background what
happened I guess Tarak will happen
because I love alright last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the initial
momentum of the Spider Man ps4 launch
do you anticipate spider-man's are
passing god of war in first month sales
numbers the winner at seventy percent in
a dominant four way ILP poll three way
I'll people is the yes mark Marvel and
Spidey momentum is too huge to stop
group coming in at 18 percent a second
place was the no God of War is a
once-in-a-generation masterpiece group
and coming in at last place at 12
percent was I don't care all my money is
going to NBA 2k DC group oh the Lord
King Lord King feel about this
considered you have a bit more data well
you know me and my little buddy here
we wait for those numbers to come
rolling in I guess what would you pick
I mean I gotta go with spider-man just
kidding it's Marvel and spider-man and
like is it big first party game like
these kind of it's one of those events
like you see how big this stuff is
lately like it's gonna do well
absolutely we'll have a new pole cooking
up at the end of the show let's fly
through these toppers we are running
late so let's get into it
Lord Soph we had a direct direct we
finally got oh we finally got the direct
we were supposed to get about a week and
a half ago after the earthquake in
Hokkaido kind of held that up so let's
go through some of the main points of
the direct in terms I'm totally happy
that which continues to be a port
machine give me all those ports we'll be
getting new super mario brothers you
deluxe which i and at some point we're
probably gonna get an announcement
autumn mario maker and someone were
probably get that um in terms of new
announcements we got um city skylines
that's coming that's a big game to go on
this way that's a huge hopefully yeah
i've seen some early stuff on that it
doesn't look so great
yeah yeah
original Gameboy monochrome did you know
we're getting a new RPG from Game Freak
that is not Pokemon related called town
well it the the that the name right now
is town which is just interesting the
fact they're doing something other than
Pokemon um then we're getting we had a
name for the Yoshi game is called
Yoshi's crafted world
it looks very cutesy yes it was slowed
down in that by the way it's also an
Unreal Engine 4 game which I thought was
kind of funny like what Yoshi game like
a busy of biggest announcements in terms
of new stuff so we're getting a Luigi's
Mansion 3 coming out finally finally
Animal Crossing is coming to the switch
next year as well yes big I just want to
shout out to Nintendo for being some of
the biggest trolls ever I was just a
reaction and my man Kofi literally
thought they were just announcing a it
was a as a character in smash a
character expansion I thought he was
about to start crying on stream like I
was kind of waiting for them to like
finish that up and then all of a sudden
like or waluigi shows up you should have
seen his face he's like I just got the
nest no doubt house it has a good
clothes vessel I think it was a great
direct for them I think we talked about
what's with Nintendo it's always to
worry about what's coming next in terms
of first party they've been able to fill
a lot of the void with great indie
support um and now they're showing what
they have coming down the pipeline for
next year they have we just mentioned
three yeah Mansion 3 you have Animal
Crossing Metroid maybe
gonna throw water on top of it I had so
many inboxes in my Twitter about the
fact that they are actually bringing
original content so I can just get off
my high horse and stop you know raining
down on you guys and what actually put
me off and you already know what put me
off is I purchased this game from our
Wii U which is actually viable which I
actually use I got my original tablet
that I play all right um but I purchased
those games I actually supported them
and I'm not gonna repurchase these games
just to say I can move away from the TV
to go upstairs to play them no all right
so I'm happy with original content games
and I do look forward to those game
that's it I might even go at your direct
I'm not a bother to work I'm foot listen
me take me for addict word for it and
addict is saying that it is the best
direct that they had kudos to you I'm
going to watch but I got burnt with the
last direct that I watched at e3 yes and
I start there with Lord Cognito
me and him alone we started in the womb
with 15 and it was down the toothbrush
and I'll say October Channel Lord Gary
crew oh la la crew gone oh yeah we were
not happy with that as great as what
it's worth just please please I need to
build up the courage to watch it again
jump itself when you finish I got a lot
to say on this I mean yeah I just think
I'm not even mad at them for continuing
to support 3ts Matt this point 3ds is
also a port machine they're getting
bowser's Inside Story you're getting
Kirby's Epic Yarn coming to 3ds um also
getting a snort link for us which I was
a big one to write that was big with the
Star Fox obviously
about this game let's be real don't let
me tell you I didn't until I got a
chance go behind the scenes at e3 with
it and act I didn't care about the toy
portion there's like a toy component
think that game looks amazing it look
the toy porn is cool which is obviously
I don't care about the kind of stuff but
I noticed a lot of the kids and a lot of
people that were playing it they were
big on the toy thing but the game really
felt like a spiritual successor to Star
Fox and they have starfox character
integration I thought it looked cool
like a video up when you're able to take
the toy in the real time and to remove
weapons off the toy and to put it back
on and that toy is interacting in real
time Nintendo again has struck gold I
love their me bow line so I think I'm
going to purchase them stay very close
to this game this is original content
and they're using the system and
different when unique wins all right I
didn't buy that cardboard stuff all
right
I still got my cardboard and waiting for
them to make this viable but they they
kind of broke down the Nintendo online
service is just gonna start on the 18th
officially 20 NES games I think if
there's anything to really attack them
it's you know the the details of this
that we've been talking about forever at
nausea yeah I mean it is what it is you
know it is what it is we'll see how this
thing this stuff evolves over time and
then down to the reason why addict
thinks it's the best direct they do
there's a whole lot of final fantasy
coming to as well as Xbox and
PlayStation man if you've read each
itself it's off already
I'm ready I'm chomping at the bit first
of all you don't say before I want to
salute good friends of Rome lore MPD's
all board members piscatella
because prior to this and then after the
dis he's remained consistent and he said
with his Nintendo Swift predictions he
remains bullish on a switch and I
remember he broke the internet earlier
this year he had
Nintendo switch contracted me the
best-selling console of q4 and 2018 and
he slowly based it on the hype of the
let's go Pokemon let's go games and
smash now I gotta keep it real with char
and I have a confessional radical King
gonna be surprising about say the thing
is coming in the opposite you guys know
I'm a huge which guy but coming into
2018 I gotta be real with cha not that I
was losing confidence I just wasn't
happy I was almost felt like they were
sitting on their loyal Lords you know of
yo we got smash we've had Pokemon at the
end of the year so to me almost felt
like a theoretically they were coasting
not that they didn't have any games it
had a lot of info from left mochi Loki
because they had such a tremendous first
year and it almost felt like it was bang
her after bang or every other month it
whether it was a new IP whether it was
spittoon whether it was comms
it was something consistent and I I love
that launch of 2017 but 2018 I just
thought was very slow as far as the big
titles and it was just way too indie
dominant and my love let me just rip it
real quick let's go come on come on
let's go
I mean you say it the first year was all
bangers and you're absolutely right
that's the issue like all the
development teams are working on those
games they've games and now it's like
alright next year what are they doing
well they're making more games but you
know they're obviously not gonna be able
to hit 2018 because they just finished
those other big games so you're correct
yeah I think that's really the main
thing is they just they put they put so
much so much getting all that stuff out
in year one on the switch that they kind
of ran dry yeah like all the other
projects are building up behind the
scenes
that's why we've seen a lot of ports as
well and yes this director I think was
kind of a hint at some of the stuff to
come I guess there's still plenty more I
mean what one of the Mario Odyssey and
breath of the wild guys doing like who
knows but it won't see it for another
two or three years but I bet we'll see
another zelda for the whole generation
of the 3ds
[Laughter]
I'm just a bit greedy because like you
said they all the 2017 was so great the
ball says so high and like you said now
those teams may be working on other
things and again it wasn't an offer yet
and make no mistake financially they're
still doing fine you know every day they
are still doing great there's no path
traveller you know that they do it so
well it just like I said I just
selfishly felt okay I won I'm all I want
that taste that I had before me - yeah
absolutely
so now 20 who this direct command and
King of Kings accurate with the e3
direct
I was expecting bigger things - I was
disappointed because um you know to
smash focus in an almost felt like hey
man you guys can save some of this stuff
for later like you have to give us so
now a distillate does bring it all in to
this correct I can't front this gave me
renewed confidence and you showed that
not only do is the future bright you
know we still have stuff coming this
year
I love the warframe announcement I
thought that was cool I thought the
Diablo announced it was cool
civilization was a big get obviously the
Luigi game obviously you know the UM
what you call it the other animal
crossing so it's just like expectation
for my nose so I just want to say this
right um at what point in time does
pretend to turn into waste right so they
they have a ton of potential and they
could potentially do it but they're
potentially not gonna get it done and it
can put - I'm tired of hearing the
potential part of you brought the
headset do you remember I just
take you back to your initial purchase
nobody's work no one I hope for tonight
but neatly you use it for fortnight with
yourself oh yeah no no with that with
the extra hand you to work around one of
me every ILP that I record cardio why
did you buy this stupid that's it
you know the switch is not gonna support
that I'm telling it and you were correct
until finally I got a chance to use it
because this is a game that supports
that you voice chat with the headset oh
the game that you don't really like but
listen listen I must say this right you
held on to your guns
and he finally gave you one game usual
$60 headset on god bless you I expect
more I demand more where's Netflix on
this little thing reach I'm really upset
with the fact that I told you guys I saw
the tea leaves and Nintendo hand must be
forced they must be thrown down the well
in order to climb out and right now
they're not nowhere near the well Oh
winning and that's how I lost that bet
you don't want because I can't
understand how they're winning I really
can't understand it and I can't get a
grasp on it because I don't stand doing
everything that just pokes them Phil if
any one of these systems told you if
Microsoft or Sony told you oh we're
gonna log online there's gonna be twenty
dollars there's no voice chat exam and
you say I'm not playing that I'm not a
part of that you guys actually said yes
and what made it worse is they said
listen you can purchase a dis online
stuff with us cuz after this day you
can't change your name you like them you
start alright and they said listen also
whatever games you did saved it if you
miss a payment they did their wife their
gun and you said okay for life still
winning the soul I have no excuses I
have no words for you guys you guys are
this is a cult is a cult now it's a KO
basically I bet if I get a good one of
those quick points on there you know
stuff like missing services like Netflix
and such it's like really need Netflix
on the switch I mean you probably got it
on the TV on the Xbox got on your phone
I want my youtube I want digital foundry
[Laughter]
it is found in a certain basic console
features that should be very I mean even
the Vita had party chat and you know a
dedicated service even reference and
that's all the hard way in their
previous iteration with the we'd you
want to go beyond that I just did that
that video on the 360 conference mmm
Microsoft was doing the stuff you can't
even send messages to your friends
messages talking listless I am so I am
so used to modern technology like when I
when I play my switch and like something
pops up Oh Lord cogniat is on like I
expect when I click his name it goes to
his profile you click his name it's just
like what are you trying to do they say
this is that needle you know Zelda
splits for is to let you know what your
friends might be doing horrified stalker
list but I will say this again with all
the snafus of you know things that
should be obviously handled I have to
say the NES online games kind of
impressed me though I like I got my I
got my pro wrestling I got but the
classic ninja gayden and then they had
they also had our own this wasn't on NES
online but the Capcom beat of my pack
was announced and then obviously you
know Final Fantasy which is addict hard
I thought that was huge and the final
point I will say is that further direct
itself I really really feel this is not
a shot of my god you know all of us rock
but inside Xbox really needs to take a
cue from these guys because again
it was short it was concise information
packed and at the very end a nice little
tribute a nice little faker a nice
little one more thing moment they didn't
intend oh the King and Sony got does
that very well to wit just mansion I
knew they had the kool-aid the children
can is it non grape or I'm sitting here
drinking berry and it don't taste as
good as yours I guess as a show in what
is it 30 minutes 40 minutes when it
information information nice surprise
nice fanservice
but I'm done written Lord Linderman
floors yours what do you think about the
direct what stood out to you impression
oh I mean I already said Luigi's Mansion
3 so that's come out there arena it's
it's great to see more stuff kind of in
the worst from Nintendo and I I'm happy
that we actually got that stuff after
the three direct which was just smash
yes I'm a little disappointed that we
didn't get a look at Metroid yeah and we
didn't get to see what is some whatever
retro studios is working on I mean I
guess you know tropical freeze which was
a port came out recently on the switch
but I really you know they have to be
working on something we've heard those
rumors about the Star Fox racing game
and yeah I mean it sounds weird but I'm
absolutely willing to see what it
becomes it's fascinating thing so at
this point we're willing to do anything
to play something on the side right just
hate for no reason due to in particular
do not see the Swiss for what it really
is yes they want they want to market it
to you home console it doesn't matter I
don't played that way at all you market
it as a console time
you don't see what we still with our two
eyes no am I gonna come home and put my
switch in the dock and play that above
my ex on my ps4 90% of the time no no
I'm not and you guys don't play it on
the go on the go so the fact that you
guys don't utilize it in the form that
it has I've never attacked the fact that
it's a dual system actually champion
that alright I actually think that's a
great thing because remember I have my
Nvidia shield I was I was going around
with the shield
alright every iteration that it popped
up I purchased so when I noticed the
chipset was inside the switch I said man
name on it then they did their cloud
situation is gonna be France as I told
you and video was doing great things
with the cloud that I think you can
transport right over or port over to the
switch in a way when I played the
Resident Evil I was like oh it looks
like PlayStation type graphics it's
really good um I'm with this part right
now but then when you tell me we giveth
and we taketh away
like I'm not about to take us away part
like what the sound okay just somebody
in the chat just said is a technique
system like it's like you you you you
you hop on you see you boy you can't
jump in and say hey I'm on once again
once again you got you guys can't I
don't care that I don't I don't need to
know what you're doing right now and I
really thought we was gonna be I see
you're attacking the viability of the
machine because of how you choose to
engage with but the exact reason on the
other side is how you choose to engage
but that's how if you I would say this
and I'm gonna I'm gonna make a blanket
statement here I would say most people
that that are especially all
the games that are into the switch big
time it's why are you avoiding my Tyrese
why are you avoiding my my my problems
with it my problem is not what you're
trying to say you're trying to - well
I'm trying to say is they told you
recently the other day you canceled our
subscription this Ames is dead I told
you this certain day you can no longer
get rid of your name off of this switch
it's bonded to you by a console you
can't to Xbox Live your games a goal to
go on very true you talking about saves
compared to games that they lend you but
I'm just saying like you just defended
right there with the whole mess with
Microsoft and if I stop doing this dis
goes away you're right you just want
them to be Microsoft this is the big
problem with the switch in terms of
that's very specific area and it's the
save system essentially users have no
way to keep their saves there's no way
to copy it to USB
there's no way to back this up and
everything is tied to that specific
system yeah problem that's the big
problem still with the switch is
everything is limited or set up kind of
per system right so I have two switches
here because one of them is modded for
portable capture so if I owned a game
digitally which I don't have that many
digital games and switch but I wanted to
use that account on the other switch and
can't do it without like basically
turning one of them from the primary to
the secondary and I kind of stuff it's a
huge pain in the ass so all of that
stuff is backwards and it's it needs to
be fixed I'm not sure it will be but it
does but I think the reason the switch
is appealing still to me and a lot of
is that it's kind of feels like
old-school console gaming away like it's
almost it that comes with some some
negatives and positives obviously but
this is just like I Bhosle buy switch
games on their little cards and it's
very old-school you pop the card in the
system the menu is as simple as like the
Dreamcast menu it's just icons it's very
very fast animalistic minimalistic it's
all about slamming that card and your
systems play the game and it's it's a
different thing now I wouldn't say I
want all systems to be this way but I
appreciate that this one specifically is
like that and you know a lot of the
extra functions like the multiplayer
stuff like that's not really that
important to me on the switch because
that's not where I'd want to be playing
those types of games anyway right right
it's like if it doesn't have it's like
whatever it's like it doesn't matter to
me for that system and let me double
down on that yes I think where the
disconnect is between me and solve and
and now I'm king an addict is that the
reason again
besides the portability you know the way
I look at it like I love the Vita right
I thought the video was really something
special because you had almost you know
PlayStation quality graphics on the go
and I think with this is that the
Nintendo switch kind of falls in that
medium which is more a little bit more
powerful than the 360 and the ps3 but
obviously not fully capable to handle
all the ps4 and Xbox one stuff to me
that's great I'd love to mine through
six I it's great when I see those games
on my platform because I'm having that
kind of power and fidelity on in a
portable situation I think it's amazing
but I understand but don't get me wrong
I do understand what they're talking
about we're talking so I might like to
give it and take away and the basic
features like adding King they are big
on that and I get that like for me not
to have those features on the friend
list especially when they're on the way
you exactly it is and don't get a I'm
which are like there's no excuse why
those features are not there that's what
we affectionately call grandpa Nintendo
decision process it just feels like
they're protecting us from ourselves for
no reason I don't get it
where I do understand what they say it
what it's just again it's what you're
looking for in a system if those things
are important you are not gonna like to
switch at the end of the day like I feel
like the reason I bought a switch is
entirely different the reason sovereign
bought a switch
cuz I bought a switch to fancy or Zelda
okay sure other stuff came out I tried
Mario to see it wasn't for me now I'm
going to be playing luigi's mansion
it's just Nintendo's games don't appeal
to me like they appeal to sovereign like
when it comes to indie games stuff like
that I'm not waiting two months to play
something on the switch I'm not gonna
play it on the switch because it's
portable like if it's all mine Xbox
doesn't a people hit on the Xbox right
so let but alright
we've the reasons I bought it and the
reasons you bought it you played it for
that mobility also two saws points I'll
let you jump in but I saw Spock the I
won't play an indie on Xbox one and ps4
I'm not gonna come home stop playing my
Triple A experience with you own no but
then now are really thriving is switch
and you notice now they're getting them
first and they offered a date offers so
that's what it's perfect like this
little quick kind of but those saves
though you just scared me that's the
biggest unacceptably and you know I feel
the same way it's unacceptable my thing
is this I've come to the point where
Nintendo Nintendo doesn't care what oh
you care about there just think man if
you're a Nintendo fan you learn to do
that continue banging my head against
the wall asking for stuff when it comes
to comes it if it comes it comes cool
what we do with the Xbox and PlayStation
all the time yeah when they want to set
the standard for that Xbox in particular
like this started out in this car day
when we started out this
and I'm just gonna agree to disagree
that rope down tried to get you out guys
don't accept it for what it is you guys
want it to be something else what I want
to get Kings next because he waited two
weeks King the floor is yours we are to
move on persistent online gaming alright
I've noticed that I've become something
that I despised um I despise the
collectors I despised that guy at I went
inside the store to purchase a game with
no hopes and opening up that game and
putting their game on the shelf just to
say I have a stack look at my stack man
I've become that guy and I sat there and
I said at what point in time did this
happen because I remember purchasing
systems for games and playing those
games and beaten those games with low
kognito and Lord sovereign delorca Basu
and Lord sent us there we sat in the
house and we did these things we
purchased these games we ended these
games we saw credits off of every game
that we purchased every Mario game that
came out for a Nintendo Super Nintendo
every Sonic game that came out for Sega
Saturn Dreamcast I seen credits I got to
the end I even played Crazy Taxi to get
to an ending this is what I'm trying to
say is these four systems online games
has changed me I've noticed now that I'm
playing destiny 10 hours a day or I jump
in pub G for five hours I get absolutely
nowhere then there's no ending to this
there's just more of the same and
tomorrow there'll be a daily and
tomorrow there'd be another strike shall
we hurry up so I can get my daily
you see do you understand what I'm
saying but then I also notice I purchase
spider-man yes and I needed to get to
light level 550 to do the raid but my
spider-man is sitting there in a wrapper
I didn't finish god of war because they
dropped out forsaken and a pub G had an
update and it was some other game that I
was playing persistently online and it
has turned me into that guy that I
despise that collected and then I
noticed in my chance everybody has a
stack mm-hmm so what I'm saying is being
that we've turned into these collectors
because I'm pretty sure I'm not the only
person is it more viable to purchase a
game pass or service of this nature that
allows us to play these games
that's in there for the $10 a month and
save our hard-earned 70 bucks every
month or every other week for new games
so we can get a chance to play inside
game pass is it is it going this way are
you are you saying that is it better for
us to play games consistently throughout
years or play one-and-done games well
what I'm saying is is it better to take
that $70 there Louise no no because
Microsoft has actually made my choice
easy to not purchase another Microsoft
game again and just stay on game pass
because all of their first party games
will be launching in game paths first so
is this the new way that we're gonna
start consuming games to start
eliminating that stack instead of
purchasing games and not getting around
to it while in conjunction playing our
online persistent games we have these
games available and we can get to them
at a later date opposed to clunking down
$60 and then in two months already $20
come Black Friday you're in wasted money
in the beginning
let's get loan liniment on this what do
you feel about that all oh man that's an
interesting one so for me I don't really
play persistent online games most of the
time not that's not my thing so
although I did play a lot of original
destiny by now the the main issue with
you bring up the old games you see the
credits on him a lot and that's true
I've actually seen the credits on more
retro games this year than anything
modern by far the problem for me with
modern games is actually that they're
too big for their own good yeah it's bad
I think all we got to make this value
for the consumer so this world game with
a billion sidequest and collectively and
even and they often make it so that the
the not the natural narrative flow is
gay gated behind this stuff yes and it
feels like if you're not spending your
time as Y Z as you could like there's
not seen all the best stuff of the game
instead you're like funneling through
very repetitive tasks to taking
advantage of this world like it
open-world games you just spend half the
time literally running from one end of
the map to the other and that's not that
fun so it's like the games have changed
in a way so whether you're playing
online or you're playing a lot of the
big modern games like that's why I do
tend to prefer those games that are
pretty linear or like constrained
because one that the experience is
generally better throughout in the sense
that you're there more consistently at a
high level because the linear thing and
so every time I sit down and play
further feels like I'm getting getting
more out of it personally and also I
know that you know I can actually reach
the end and then move on yes that's kind
of the type of game I prefer to play
more often just for that reason so I
kind of bounce between retro games and
those and those are also the types of
games that I like to own I like to find
those on disc or cart because those
types of experiences I'm gonna go back
to eventually and have a good time I
don't care that much about owning like
all the Assassin's Creed games on discs
because I do have plenty because they're
so long I'm never ever gonna replay them
I don't really care about owning a
destiny or
you know online games on discs because
when the servers
go off there did you yeah he lose you
lose the game doesn't yeah I would I do
like to collect and I like to own two
physical copies of those games that are
good enough and concise enough that
they're possible to replay in a
reasonable amount of time and they're
enjoyable to replay it's like you put a
movie on your shelf and you go back to
that movie every so often you have a
great time and join it again and that's
these are the types of fascination game
I like on my shelf as well and that's
especially true retro games which is why
I like collecting him a lot because you
can you I like to sit down so you know I
have a friend over something where you
like alright what game are we gonna beat
today that's how you pop you pop a
cartridge in or a disk or something and
you just spend the afternoon blasting
through it you reach the end and you had
an awesome time awesome job that is a
great thing and that reminds that
reminds me of what I love about games in
general is like mastering those concise
challenges it's like and that's actually
one of the things that that's one of the
reasons I think that the Dark Soul
series became popular it's not just
that's difficult but it's constrained
enough and the challenge is narrow
enough where you always feel like
alright I can go back and I can I can
get better at this very specific point
and you feel satisfied with mastering a
series of small challenges that come at
you one after another but it's not so
big that you've got like a billion
things to do in the world
and that's really satisfying and that's
what makes a lot of classic games great
and that's you know so that's the stuff
I want to own and then the stuff you're
talking about like the online
persistence stuff that's a great case
for something like game pass those types
of games where you know you don't really
need it on disk because the you know
you're not gonna it's not a collectible
kind of game instead that's the kind of
thing where you're gonna connect to a
service you're gonna play it with some
friends and you're gonna have a great
time and the value comes from the
memories you have and the fun times you
have while playing it with other people
and the social experience and it's two
very different things and honestly
open-world games are often like that too
where I would say hey play play that on
game paths have a blast and like you
know one of my favorite experiences this
year was actually see of Thieves I know
like not too many people seem to have
loved it but yes it wasn't really uh I
liked that it was a very simple kind of
game you know what I mean like I didn't
feel again to work about a million
little things again I Gillian but it's
like just going out like I think the
first couple days with that game was one
of my favorite experiences this year
because you know I connected with some
friends were just on voice chat and even
though we would discover the loop of the
game is fairly simplistic at the time
which we didn't actually know know what
it was what are you even doing what we
even doing so the communication was
necessary to get things ooh yeah just
that experience sailing around and
countering other players like all the
things that happened out there like it
was all very simple stuff but it was
engaging because it was so it just it
felt fun and I really liked that type of
experience and that's why I'm not so big
into the games where it's just like you
know you have to level up and worry
about all these little things and what I
plated this me - because Bungie knows
how to do gun play like record gameplay
leave destiny is really good it's really
is good and there's some amazing level
design and visual design they've done an
awesome job on that but for me it's like
with destiny - it's like I play through
destiny - and I didn't feel the need to
just keep coming back I don't get what
people do but it's like when people
finish it real quick or you know I just
treated it like a single-player games
but yeah we're not playing with campaign
if you were good yeah it's like I beat
it I had an awesome time I look back on
it fondly but it's okay I don't need to
keep coming back to it I mean I know
it's all how you are warming Lord sobs
heart right now - DJ stick in the chat
he said that Lord saw just got a partner
for single cell for single player his
spirit is lifted he's like yes I have
found a brother apartment
I understand I do not need persistent
online I do not be I want my
single-player linear experience where
you have that sense of accomplishment
and you can go back you can replay it
and do things but like you don't
understand how much you speak for me go
to the point about like having a stack
of games and having that that collection
I've largely gone digital I'm basically
on completely digital that said my
digital stack is just as big as what my
physical stack would be if not even more
like between between Xbox Playstation
and switch I probably have 700 games
that's that's ridiculous fully admit
that is ridiculous and I don't get to
touch you know we a small portion of
that that said my goal is at some point
to be able to play at least some of all
of those games I'm a virtual hoarder
that exactly and I will and I will
dedicate time and like a lot of time to
specific games that I know I would like
I'll finish everything in that game and
then other ones who probably sit there
and touch for quite some time and then
when I do touch them is not necessarily
guarantee that I'm gonna really play
through them so that's that so I do the
same thing in the digital room is I
probably would have done physically oh
so when it comes to those persistent
online games yes for me the same thing I
there's not one of those games that I
would probably ever stick to over a long
period of time much like like like like
John said like destiny - I played it at
launch I was on at launch pretty much
just as much as you guys are at much and
then completely no I was on destiny I
was on the old original destiny no
destiny - oh no a lot of destiny that
first three weeks without I don't know
did not indicate anything that you're
saying sir
you stay in the tower and look I like to
stop and smell the roses and look at
stuff like I don't I don't play games
like that is what I do so for me nobody
beat spider-man and I didn't so I need
to shut up nobody wants to be on my
destiny team someone like dude look at
this texture look at that HDR
implementation I think the weirdest
thing I do real quick here it's like you
get a game for review and you get the
digital code and then cover it like
games that I really like I end up just
like buying a physical copy and just
keep it shrink-wrap like I look over
here saying oh I got gears of war for
you that's a lot of kids I played I
played the game like I buy games already
heavily yes I truly don't believe in
this online stuff right I truly don't
because I come from having you know the
games so any game just like he said that
I truly like I purchased the physical
copy and I'll leave it there just in
case the service if something goes down
and some bad happens play the game I
love contender by the way is like you
know we if you bought whole Wii U
digital stuff and love addict bear what
do you feel with the whole person online
in single play game thing where you have
a sense I got problems to persist online
games if I'm willing to say addict
finish this thing off with uh with you
the Xbox and now
I just want to like you know this isn't
gonna be too long I did notice that you
know let me tell you the the how this
went through I was making a video
because I was playing destiny and wasn't
on Twitter like crazy and I watched a
Nintendo Direct which I want to point
out Lord kognito was gonna watch if he
decided not to because he's dude
disappointed what the previous ones yeah
so I watch this and I was like yo they
have Final Fantasy 10 they have all
these great Final Fantasies coming out
but it's still not on Xbox what's with
that so I started making my video that
was pretty much like this needs to
change this is dumb hey no no it's out
so I want to point out that I think it's
a little bit different that they're on
that Final Fantasy 10 and all them are
on switch because they have a better
relationship with square because they
used to be primarily on Nintendo but
look at Final Fantasy 10 it's been out
on three platforms even steam never been
on on Xbox Final Fantasy 9 has only been
on square on so many products but now
it's recently went on Steam and outs on
xbox so I want to like formally admit
that those pitchers do with his work
would it save your Xbox only-begotten
son these are eager games that I truly a
hunter I think was ever gonna see 10 it
was remade for for the ps3 it was remade
for the ps4 it got released on Steam
never on Xbox so it just that you know
people are like oh now this game now we
need Kingdom Hearts 1 & 2 I kind of feel
I should do it I kind of feel like this
this whatever agreement was up I feel
like was neither bought out or it was or
the time ran out because I feel like if
this game was going to come out on Xbox
and it was possible it would it came out
during the ps4 when that remake was
launched what with the
the Final Fantasy 10 because I I'll okie
feel like Nintendo's responsible for
this like I feel like Nintendo went
through the proper channels to make this
game possible come out to multiple
platforms that Xbox took that advantage
because I feel like Xbox this game would
have Final Fantasy Tim when it came out
for the Xbox during the ps4 when that
when he was relaunched to the ps4 at the
Xbox at the same time there's a reason
at theat that the switch and the Xbox
both were announced in the same day
because I feel like whatever a Nintendo
did to make that come on the switch it
was used to get on the Xbox - that's
interesting interesting theory interest
yeah time except you know what what did
you feel about the announcement with the
Final Fantasy series actually hitting
xbox honestly really not a lot of the
those games have hit the platform and
just some shuttle was sent over in the
chat so yeah he said Square Enix seems
to have changed their Xbox approach post
near automata
he said they realized there is the
market for those games so I just what
your whole feeling about that was Square
and in the Final Fantasy I think it's
awesome that more people can finally
play these games they should I'm glad
that those walls seem to be coming down
I'd assume that in the past it was more
like Japanese thinking like okay with
say all right you know PlayStation Japan
and tend to Japan but you know Xbox has
really never taken off there but maybe
they're taking a more global view of
things now I don't even think it was
necessarily that because 15 and 13 came
out before that REMIC attained yeah
that's a good point actually yeah it's
kind of a weird situation there the 10:1
I don't understand but uh games like
Final Fantasy 7 9 don't those are weird
releases to me because I don't really
think that they work that well on modern
displays like because of the super low
respect like you gotta play those on a
CRT like it right like this isn't like
those backgrounds don't look good but at
the same time you know I I think it's
really awesome that they're coming and
it's you know it's a it's especially
funny to see Final Fantasy 7 on a
Nintendo system on a cartridge since the
whole market
the game back in the day it'll never
come to go you know it's not really the
same thing I understand but it's it's
it's funny it's it's gonna see it and I
think Square should absolutely be
bringing more of their back catalog to
all the systems creators create people
people want this stuff and they'd like
to read there's a lot of people that
haven't played them maybe people that
want to replay them and like limited it
to one platform it's just leaving money
on the table and point out you know key
to Mars 3 is about to come out next year
yeah and square is going to post this on
Xbox Kingdom Hearts 3 but not the
previous ones I do feel like there's a
publishing thing there with Sony because
that's not even on that Tendo
well Nintendo did have some Kingdom
Hearts games on would they have some of
them but they don't include yes they
they have some but they don't have a lot
of the the collections on like Kingdom
Hearts 1 & 2 those have never been on
Nintendo but once people really want
I feel like squared doesn't really have
the right to complain about cells on a
platform that they didn't release the
predecessors of that game on them I
don't I don't know about this but I
wonder if any of that has to do with
some old licenses I was just about to
ask I like the number of platforms are
allowed to release it like totally off
but there could be something there with
the Disney relationship yes specific
game contracts that might muddy the
waters and that's what I was talking
about with the Final Fantasy 10 9 and 7
is those games I feel like had that
speculation but when a Tendo went about
to get it on their platform I feel like
they did something to stop that entirely
because question I have those do we even
know that Nintendo was responsible for
that like it almost makes it if it's
just Square and it was just weird where
else I guess make money yeah was that I
don't know you talked about this last
night and we were like is it really
Microsoft you know working hard to get
these on their platform or is it a
business move but look at it from the
standpoint that they've released they
released the Final Fantasy 9 on
PlayStation 4 then like two months later
they were knows like four or five months
ago then they released it on Steam same
thing with the fine
Phantasy tends been released on two
different platforms before I went to
Xbox and these games aren't coming out
anytime soon they're coming out next
year mm-hmm
Final Fantasy 12 was released on
PlayStation and they I don't think
that's on Steam but my point is it is so
you got these games and I feel like when
it comes to this standpoint if these
games were coming out on Xbox and they
were available to I feel like they would
have I mean I don't know if this this
holds any water but it could also be a
development thing like are you gonna
really put I don't know how much in
terms of resources is it is it gonna
cost you to develop a remaster of these
games simultaneously for all these
platforms at once rather than focusing
on one platform first to see how it
sells it and seeing if that if it makes
sense for you financially to put them on
the other console that table but the
fact that Final Fantasy 15 13 13 - 13
lightning returns it seems like they're
up until now there's been something
preventing them from coming to other
platforms because these games have only
been on PlayStation and steam that's all
until a lot of these rerelease has only
started happening this gen right like
most of those games kind of stayed to
their original platform until recently
and then I think Square Enix of today
has started to realize the value of
re-releasing old games which is
something they weren't that into before
I mean they've done some but I mean they
were released the Kingdom Hearts
Japanese companies know the value of a
dollar like Capcom they will release
that game oh yeah
they brought they brought Final Fantasy
7 to every platform Sony said they just
brought nine back that I don't think
it's ever gonna come back unless they do
some magical stuff but uh I mean it is
what it is I'm just glad that you know I
think this is a good standpoint for the
Xbox as a brand because absolutely in
order to I've always said because you
know people always have that stigma that
you know these games don't sell well in
Xbox because they don't get the good
ones at these games they always get the
average ones or bad one of these
seems like these Final Fantasy games
like look dragons of Dragon Quest like
we Xbox don't get those the good Gao
RPGs that Xbox kids always sells go good
a Final Fantasy 15 so good monster
hunter's look like but when it comes to
they like the middle of the average when
they never get them and they're arguably
getting some of the best ones that's
ever been made yep I'm just thinking we
need more missed Walker
shoulda bought them I don't know if they
were able to but have been there they
JRPG company I just I just played that I
think a month ago yeah just real quickly
finish no I mean yeah this is
interesting I really don't know this is
this is when I heard the announcement I
was very surprised to see you know the
Final Fantasy series there on Xbox I
thought that was great
you know I will say this you know to
King's credit I know he's big fill
friends here but um I will say that at
least Microsoft even if it wasn't as if
this was a square deal I feel lately
during the fill era especially this last
II mean they've made it a point to
embrace Japanese games and for them to
display on their stage like force and
obviously you know don't make cry and
you know this psycrow shadows not twice
where it is like there's so many times
like that wouldn't happen you know and
it would only be on the PlayStation
stage so I felt at least they are making
shrines and this is a good game
regardless to whoever made the deal and
it's a good gift for it to be on a
platform and it's beneficial for Square
you know Square I mean at the end of the
day you know you're getting your product
out there the more audiences more
platform more engagement you know so I
think it's a good thing at the end of
the day I like the move hope it
continues and just rustic we shot out
two Final Fantasy a I don't know what's
coming sooner or later there's gonna be
too much demand isn't like man let's
just do it okay hopefully maybe they
have to rewrite it but the corner you
know Lord little minis there's a lot
involved there and you know what the old
you know what you said with the old
Japanese on was it cold and stuff like
that maybe just hard to retrieve I don't
know it's just a lot of it was lost
source kill the source cover anyway
let's end it new poll this week where is
all of the recent announcements at the
latest Nintendo Direct how did this
affect your outlook on the future of the
Nintendo switch moving forward the
answers are a no effect majority of old
games and ports and terrible online
service display be huge effect ton of
great games for 2018 and beyond future
is bright or C I don't care no more
level support I start watching that is
the question those are the choices
please Rock the ILP but when it goes up
on Twitter Lord John Lennon an absolute
pleasure to have you in the room awesome
to talk with you guys as soon as I heard
about super graphics Bay your experience
is absolutely tremendous and I have to
be just like Lord King City was
fanboying out you know I got a chance to
meet you in the flesh and if--and what I
was opposed to be doing good job I
suppose to be doing coverage and I'm
like right next is Lord John I'm leaving
with shout to LA say until we were out
there he was a Microsoft president the
Xbox for next thing on the states it was
pretty awesome I had lost a toe
recovering on right shadow of the Tomb
Raider at the time we weren't allowed to
take any footage but you don't write in
the periphery good lord so unassuming no
one says anything to I'm like that is
the man right now he was so cool thank
you so much for coming through the realm
of sharing your experiences digital
foundry but again which I said the pulse
of modern gaming culture you guys do
tremendous job shout out to the team
yourself Richard Ledbetter everyone on
the team we always look forward to the
breakdown the technical analysis to
break the benchmarks fantastic job thank
you for entering the realm of the Lords
thanks for having me guys it was awesome
absolutely and we can do our outro so
Lord edit and also before I actually
pass it where can you find people find
you and
on social media and as well as what are
the next things you have actually
cooking up all right so you can find me
at dark 1x on Twitter and of course
we're on youtube.com slash digital
foundry and at your game brunette slash
digital foundry
show coming soon we got will be doing
one on on J outta dry something's coming
I got I got I got some fun uh DF write
your stuff in the works some long-term
projects that I've been working on so
hopefully it's fun presentations
happening if you come into I mean if you
happen to be in England
yes MX in Birmingham DF retro panel up
there with Matt Phillips the creator of
Tanglewood which is a brand new Sega
Genesis game whoa
the drag race he made this the old
school way it shipped on a cartridge and
he's gracious it's awesome he decided to
come on stage with me and actually talk
about how you made the game and I'm
gonna try to turn that into a video
after the fact that's awesome wow that's
a tremendous story I had no idea about
this definitely looking forward today
that is amazing absolutely the king and
Lord of retro my bad Lord addict Rick
find people find you who do you have
going on
oh you can't find me on anything right
now I'm gonna jump right back on that
Ray mentally destroyed me I refuse to go
in there unless I'm like 50 but you can
definitely catch me on twitter at a lord
addict IOP here I'm gonna go ahead and
post in the the chat this is the Twitter
for Lord John Letterman definitely go
follow him he's been a great guest
definitely go do that
and you know I want one thing I'd like
to thank Lord Linderman for coming
through so I'm out talk to you guys like
Lord
sovereign you finally melt a selfish
single-player experience
game man after my own heart
absolutely I just love today just sit
down and just disappear into a world
that's what
do so I'm glad that there's who really
who really appreciate that so Big Shot
and thank you to John layman for coming
through really um I love everything you
guys do in terms of the the technical
breakdowns of all the modern stuff and
especially the df' that the df' retro
stuff that is my favorite it speaks to
me in a way that like it's just it
allows me to go back to those old times
and and really take deep dives into
games that I just loved on the surface
and now I have because of what you do I
have more knowledge about these games
and it's amazing just keep it up please
thank you so much and you guys can find
me online you can find me tweeting
pictures of spider-man and shadow of the
Tomb Raider on Twitter at coming up -
I'll be putting a lot more that this
week good you should poster inside the
Instagram how about that that is you can
find me online as well be a covering on
Xbox Live and PSN I may not talk to you
but I'll be there with all over you -
Jason King absolute pleasure what is
good over first of all most I would like
to say anyone who understands when I say
super graphics cost me like $450 and I
purchased it for one game and I
purchased it for ghouls and ghosts that
point in time for me the system was huge
is beautiful and it said super graphics
and I felt like the biggest person in
the world
this is the first mid generation yes the
superb yes that is a graphic yes we just
know it
32-bit system because remember they had
to 16 on top of what I was a giant but
yeah today has been a great day I think
I'm gonna talk about this show the
interview more than most and it's
because you you formulate the culture
and maybe you guys didn't know what was
happening when it was happening and how
it was happening but to do something in
the manner that you have done it it
shows your excellence because everything
that you guys touch in my opinion is
gold like dénia fret row when he did
that I said yes because I remember going
to Suzy's eating or getting a pizza to
go and play this Genesis game and you
took the deep dive into that some guys
won't remember that and some guys are
getting this for the first time but for
the people that do and go back to that
when they purchase the cartridge and he
looked at it he has the time period and
a nostalgic feel when you talk about it
and it's it's it's something I truly
appreciate I appreciate you all so the
whole staff I appreciate all you guys
for everything that you do and I always
tell people look at the back of the
video when you're standing with the
stuff that's on the shelf I feel it and
I do appreciate it and you guys are
pillar in the community and we look to
you guys for the unbiased true
information on stuff so I just keep up
the great work and it was a pleasure
having you on today I try you love down
here lower liniment you love your bed
same here man obviously you guys I know
I went all with my blue vision you can
find me on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook the Facebook community is just
posters or what's coming up next
Instagram is
insight into what we do is not gonna be
any captions and stuff like that really
there you're just gonna see what us as
the Lord's just please go like a file
and subscribe the YouTube channel is
where you can actually see these videos
and you can get that stuff combat talk
is gonna be done right after this so you
can get my analysis of the results of
the fighting last night and if you
didn't see the original combat talk for
the preview of the fight you can go you
can watch that you can see how right or
wrong the king was going into this all
right at home we do appreciate everybody
sitting in this room you guys are still
44 strong we went up to 80 and that was
beautiful thank you guys for sticking
around all the way to the end before
ours is crazy
yeah it's great listen man again not
gonna be understood cannot be said that
has not already been said but again
salute Lord Hanuman coming through again
apologies for going a little long your
story's just sparking the brain and we
were just taking it back we couldn't
stop talking try not to go this long
it's like an e3 robot special right now
but oh yeah dude salute man tremendous
stories great great work you guys are
doing and again for me you know walking
around on Twitter and again thanks
everyone staying in hit that like
subscribe on all the inner circle media
network of channels and links is in the
description we'll have all that stuff
like our bots will have the timestamps
up cuz it's a long episode so look out
for that little bit later on today shout
out to the stream team gonna have some
announcements with that coming up soon
and again like what King said combat
talk is up there on the ironing board
podcast channel as well as behind the
scenes where we have two shows we have
all that stuff up to e3 packs all that
good stuff
flashpoint which is our destiny only
focused podcast that will return this
week apologies about says I had to get
ready for the raid so I ditched out on
yet back with track they start talking
that great forsaken talk this great
content in it's been a great raise good
good time to come back to the destiny if
you are curious and yeah the shirt the
audio and all that stuff will be up I
know we went long everyone kind of enjoy
your Sunday is there anything else by
anyway Lord we will close out all right
everybody's good everyone enjoyed it
you
[Music]